[Musique]
bonsoir pendant 36 jours les chefs ont
parcouru le Québec pour vous convaincre
ce soir cinq parties ont des chances de
faire élire au moins un député avez-vous
le goût d'embarquer pour un autre la
majorité des Québécois ne souhaite pas
avoir François Legault comme Premier
ministre le seul adversaire qui l'a fait
partie libéral du Québec nous on fait
campagne pour gagner on a besoin surtout
d'un nouveau projet de société je
souhaite être Premier ministre puis je
vais incarner l'espoir donc les gens ont
un choix quand même important à faire
moi j'ai confiance dans le jugement plus
d'intelligence des électeurs québécois
on va causer la surprise de rien gagner
nous sommes à la ligne d'arrivée les
chefs ont assez parlé ils attendent
votre réponse bienvenue à votre soirée
électorale
c'est important de venir voter
[Musique]
bonsoir madame et Messieurs ici patrice
Roy à toute l'équipe de l'information de
Radio-Canada en direct de l'Atrium de
cette nouvelle Maison de Radio-Canada
Sébastien Bovet bonsoir
on est toujours fébrile on a hâte
d'avoir les premiers résultats c'est
dans une heure et demie je vais vous
poser la question à tous la même
qu'est-ce que vous surveillez
particulièrement plusieurs régions moi
ma région chouchou c'est l'Est du Québec
je vais vous en parler dans un instant
mais c'est la bataille de la survie pour
le Parti québécois notamment donc je
surveille ça et plusieurs autres
circonscriptions à travers le Québec
sont à surveiller oui Chantal Hébert
bonsoir merci d'être là surveillez quoi
ce soir Camille Lauren parce que c'est
pas seulement la survie du Parti
québécois c'est le besoin pour le
particulier quoi d'avoir un chef à
l'Assemblée nationale
la survie et le retour en force du parti
passe par là donc à surveiller c'est un
gros Paris pour pas de
saint-pierre-plamondon de se présenter
là
sur l'île de Montréal ou le PQ va pas si
bien que ça donc c'est une des boîtes à
surprises de la soirée et d'ailleurs ça
fait longtemps moi je ne me souviens pas
d'une soirée électorale où la région de
Montréal est aussi intéressante que ce
soit à la question gay bonsoir beaucoup
de belles batailles régionales l'île de
Montréal aussi moi je vais surveiller
l'esprit Québec solidaire dans
Sherbrooke dans Saint-François la petite
circonscription à côté de Sherbrooke ça
peut donner l'idée de la soirée que
Québec solidaire va avoir la bataille
dans Sherbrooke contre la CAQ dans
Saint-François aussi parmi bien d'autres
circonscriptions à surveiller mais
l'esprit je vais surveiller ça du point
de l'oeil et nous serons bien sûr
beaucoup sur le terrain dans toutes les
régions du Québec et parlant de tout le
Québec on a décidé d'emmener une partie
de Québec une partie de Montréal une
partie des régions sur le plateau ici
incarnez par Regis Labeaume exmère de
Québec c'est la bonsoir bonsoir
m'annoncer mais reste actuelle vous
n'êtes pas une vraie mais reste actuelle
de chibougamo oui monsieur merci d'être
là on s'est parlé lors du déclenchement
puis à plusieurs reprises et Luc
Ferrandez
roi mère du Plateau
Mont-Royal merci d'être là je vous
pose la même question vous surveillez
quoi rapidement ce soir ben écoutez le
lieu de naissance des conservateurs
c'est la région de Québec l'épicentrer
là à moitié de surprise ailleurs il
faudrait savoir si on a soulevé le
soldat du M d'un Chauveau et si ailleurs
entre autres la bataille des poulets
dans vos Sud si je passe quelque chose
de sérieux alors c'est ça mon lieu
d'intérêt très bien Manon aussi
pour l'invitation j'aimerais saluer les
gens de leur appeler quand encore
quelques heures pour aller voter surtout
qu'il fait beau cette année et je vais
surveiller par ailleurs ou un Noranda
Témiscaming je pense que avec ce qui
s'est passé avec la fonderie les
derniers événements des derniers jours
des dernières semaines donc je pense ça
va être une lutte on est là pour une
belle soirée je comprends
Rouen c'est imprévisible monsieur le
goût a dit vous avez rencontré Monsieur
le goût à quelques jours
de loin vont décider on a devoir ça Luc
Verdun vers 2 c'est une bataille
dantesque qui sont ils sont nés à ni
tous les trois avec la même score
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une année
Isabelle Mélenchon qui était relégué aux
oubliettes qui a réussi à remonté à fort
à la force des poignets et qui
maintenant fait face à Québec soldat qui
veut absolument gagner en fait les trois
parties la carte Québec solidaire
de la partie libérale ne peuvent pas
perdre s'il perdent d'un Verdun les
trois perdent un symbole important
partie libéral serait la démonstration
qui peuvent pas gagner dans un comté qui
est à 60% francophone ils veulent avoir
sont pas capables de prendre prise sur
Montréal et ça ne pas avoir de prix sur
Montréal c'est un drame de la soirée de
ce soir il faut il y avait quelques
endroits il faut prendre prise Maurice
Richard Verdun rivière des Prairies en
jours réelles il y avait mis des ils ont
mis des bons candidats donc très
important on ira partout tout ce que
vous avez nommé on va y aller en direct
effectivement c'est des luttes à suivre
pendant qu'on voit des gens qui
continuent à voter alors la grande
question à cette heure-ci c'est ce que
les gens sont allés voter est-ce que il
y a eu un taux de participation à la
hauteur c'est un peu plus élevé on va le
voir dans le tableau plus élevé que la
dernière fois le vote par anticipation
avait été pas mal plus élevé et le vote
à cette heure-ci est plus élevé qu'en
2018 alors qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur
le résultat final avoir chacun des
expériences différentes
moi je suis allé voter ce matin il y
avait pas un chat d'autres m'ont dit il
y a plein
des lieux de votre participation c'est
le taux de participation actuellement
c'est 44%, le vote par anticipation en
2022 donc cette année a été le plus fort
depuis qu'on enregistre le vote par
anticipation est-ce que c'est plus une
affaire de logistique familiale qu'on va
voter par anticipation que plutôt de
dire que on le taux de participation va
augmenter ce soir il est à 44,6 en ce
moment on aura un dernier chiffre
évidemment dans le courant de la soie il
était pour les gens qui adorent les
chiffres il était à 41 très exactement
il y a quatre ans donc une petite
poussée faut voir il y a
6 millions 300 1.000 113 personnes très
exactement qui sont inscrits sur la
liste électorale au Québec il y a 810
candidats que l'on salue d'ailleurs pour
reprendre l'expression populaire au
Québec là ils ont mis leur face sur le
poteau la dissolution la ligne de départ
la voici
76 pour la CAQ 27 pour le Parti libéral
10 pour Québec solidaires le PQ 7 il y a
quatre indépendants et un pour le une
devrait-je dire pour le Parti
conservateur du Québec je vous rappelle
que pour avoir la majorité c'est le
chiffre magique de 63 qu'un des parties
doit atteindre Mathieu proche vous êtes
dans le bureau de vote de Verdun Luc
parlait de Verdun alors comment ça se
passe
il n'y a pas eu de fil pendant les
quelques heures qu'on a passé ici
effectivement devant ce bureau d'autre
pas de fil en moyenne je vous dirais que
tout le processus pour chaque électeur
prend à peu près deux ou trois minutes
en moyenne mais ça défile
continuellement derrière nous et Luc
effectivement le disait Verdun c'est
pourtant un endroit où chaque voix
chaque voix d'électeur va compter parce
que trois parties sont littéralement nés
à nez dans les dernières intentions de
votre KIA il y avait des inquiétudes sur
l'organisation du scrutin dans plusieurs
circonscriptions à l'échelle du Québec
ont circonscription dont trois étaient
ici sur l'île de Montréal pourquoi parce
qu'on pensait qu'ils ont manquerait
peut-être de personnel et on a travaillé
très très fort dans les derniers jours
cette fin de semaine pour recruter du
personnel ici dans Verdun jusqu'à hier
on a formé des personnes alors comment
on s'est arrangé normalement vous savez
ce duo de scrutateur et secrétaire
s'occupe d'une seule boîte de scrutin
alors dans certains cas et bien on a
poussé ça à deux donc on a doublé la
charge de travail mais comme je le dis
c'était vraiment très très fluide taux
de participation ici dans Verdun à 16
heures 47% donc un petit peu plus élevé
que la moyenne nationale que vous avez
évoquée c'était 32% à 12h30 puis ça ça
inclus évidemment le vote par
anticipation des 7 autres journées qui
ont eu lieu donc de 24 et quelques
pourcents pourquoi la participation
Patrice est importante évidemment pour
la santé démocratique de cette société
mais de manière plus prosaïque c'est
aussi pour la santé financière des
parties pourquoi parce que chaque
électeur sa représente un dollar 71
aujourd'hui en 2022 de financement pour
les parties alors on va en entendre des
électeurs vous savez il y a aussi des
petits électeurs parce qu'il y a un
programme électeur en herbe qui permet
aux enfants de se prononcer pas sur les
programmes mais sur certains choix de
société alors c'est ce que ce dont nous
parle un des pères qui est cet électeur
que j'ai interviewé en premier
c'était vraiment bien le petit va-t'on
en famille je sais pas si vous avez vu
de mise à part il y a une petite blague
maintenant il y a une belle initiative
où les enfants peuvent voter c'est super
bien mais sinon pourquoi voter c'est
important c'est un devoir je pense que
c'est important parce qu'après ben on
peut pas rien on peut pas chialer donc
si vous voulez Charlie allez votre je
pourrais pas dire qu'un parti qui m'a
plu plus plus qu'un autre par contre
c'est un peu difficile de faire le choix
puis ça m'a pris beaucoup de temps de
décider si tout le monde le fond ça fait
une différence
mais si chacun individu pense que
se dit dans un malheur mais on va jamais
voir une différence
alors c'est une des raisons que moi
très bien alors on verra si on va
dépasser le taux de participation et
plus tard dans la soirée bientôt on va
parler directement général des élections
d'ailleurs pénurie de main d'oeuvre
d'une part comment ça s'est passé
aujourd'hui etc le vote par anticipation
ça c'est une question très intéressante
pour ceux qui sont derrière qui doivent
faire des projections électorales de
votre parenticipation a-t-il été compté
d'un coup on croit comprendre que oui à
partir de 18 heures donc maintenant il
est compté ça sera vérifié il sera en
direct Sébastien votre carte va se
colorer et l'intérêt de cet outil c'est
de comparer avec 2018 voilà et je
reprends la balle au bon de Mathieu
Verdun c'est ou Verdun c'est juste ici
une circonscription intéressante parce
que il y a comme deux quartiers à Verdun
l'île des sœurs et le Verdun
traditionnel appelons-le comme ça de
tissu sociaux économiques très
différents donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle Québec solidaire pense qu'ils
ont des chances le Parti libéral et la
coalition à Québec aussi donc une lutte
à 3 dans cette circonscription Montréal
je vais vous en parler ce soir
d'habitude on vous en parle pas ou à peu
près pas de Montréal parce que
d'habitude c'est réglé c'est réglé
pourquoi parce que l'Ouest à partir
libérale le centre appartient à Québec
solidaire et l'Est traditionnellement
bleu pics mais c'est du bleu poudre qui
est arrivé en 2018 parce que la
coalition Québec a pris deux
circonscriptions la bataille elle se
fait où ce soir elle se fait ici dans
des circonscriptions comme Maurice
Richard notamment juste ici
voilà Maurice Richard qui apparaît
Verdun aussi Québec solidaire la
Coalition avenir Québec espère faire des
gains là le Parti libéral espère sauver
ses mains doux donc l'importance de
Montréal ce soir d'autres régions qu'on
surveille particulièrement je pense que
la base c'est pas votre région c'est une
de mes régions chouchou Laval est-ce que
les libéraux vont conserver leur
circonscription combien ils vont en
perdre alors il y a combien de
circonscriptions à Laval il y en a 6 il
y en a combien qui appartiennent au
libéraux 5 à la fin de la soirée la
coalition va venir Québec espère
renverser ce résultat et avoir cinq
circonscriptions si la carte peut faire
des gains sur le Parti libéral c'est
dans la région de Laval je vous amène
dans la région de Monsieur Labeau
[Rires]
Québec solidaire aussi pourquoi il y
aurait une plateauisation de la Gaspésie
je pense
peut-être pas d'accord mais il y a des
gens de la ville qui sont arrivés en
Gaspésie notamment dans le
circonscription de bonne aventure ici
celle de Gaspé qui donne espoir à Québec
solidaire parce que ça va se
matérialiser ce soir faudra bien voir et
en terminant vous vous dites Sébastien
bave et dit n'importe quoi je vais faire
ma propre carte électorale ce soir je
vais jouer moi Sébastien Bobet vous
pouvez le faire sur le site de
Radio-Canada donc vous avez la carte
électorale il y a pas de couleur parce
que les résultats sont pas encore
arrivés vous pouvez aussi vous trouver
des circonscriptions que vous voulez
surveiller donc par exemple Anjou Louis
Riel sur l'île de Montréal qui est une
circonscription qu'on va surveiller des
candidats que vous voulez suivre ici on
a mis les 5 chefs pour que vous puissiez
lécher les suivre c'est vous qui faites
les choix en passant et vous favoris
aussi donc vous pouvez choisir une
circonscription favorite et suivre donc
trouver que je parle pas assez de votre
circonscription par exemple vous pouvez
suivre en temps réel votre description
et jouer à ce que je fais moi sur ce
plateau c'est fascinant parce que vous
expliquiez ça et déjà nous inviter ce
soir donc c'est réglé mais c'est un site
je le rappelle à chaque fois qui est
vraiment très agréable très facile
d'accès qu'on peut faire sa liste
électorale avec vous le connaissez bien
aussi absolument puis ça permet d'avoir
donc plusieurs circonscriptions qu'on
surveille en même temps parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de belles batailles ce soir on
parle de qui va former le gouvernement
oui c'est important mais la dynamique de
l'Assemblée nationale va être transformé
à chaque élection c'est le cas donc
est-ce qu'on va avoir davantage de ce
qu'on va des conservateurs pour la
première fois est-ce qu'on va avoir
davantage de Québec solidaire est-ce que
le PQ va garder ses circonscriptions ça
il va y avoir une influence sur les
quatre prochaines années et donc vous
pouvez suivre ça aller chercher les
circonscriptions qui vous qui qui sont
d'intérêt puis on va pouvoir suivre sur
la soirée et globalement aussi plus
profondément la question qu'on se pose
Chantal c'est est-ce que on a redessiné
la carte électorale en 2018 au Québec
avec la CAQ est-ce que on fait un pas de
plus aujourd'hui ou ça reste avec cinq
parties politiques comme ça est-ce qu'on
est un entre deux à quelle mesure on va
avancer ou pas dans cette direction
d'abord le fait que 5 que partie qui
sont donc quatre sont à peu près à
égalité ce que ça dit c'est qu'on n'est
pas en train de revenir en arrière si on
est en train de revenir en arrière on
dirait le PQ va peut-être revenir une
partie libérale on n'est pas du tout
dans cette dynamique là donc on est
selon moi encore dans une période de
transition et quand on regarde la
dynamique de la campagne ce qu'on peut
se dire c'est que 2018 c'était pas un
accident une tocade un peu comme la
bague orange en 2011 qui a passé puis
que laisser quelques petits morceaux de
sable c'est pas ça du tout
la balance la coalition à venir Québec
ce serait la première fois si François
Legault l'emporte ce serait la première
fois depuis 2008 qu'on garde le même
parti au gouvernement deux fois de suite
ce qu'on faisait toujours avant
c'était pas l'exception mais là c'est
comme si on avait essayé tout le monde
puis finalement elle coalition
il y a pas de sentiment de on revient à
ce que c'était et on va voir dans les
résultats comme vous dites mais deux
mandats d'une part et ça risque d'être
un mandat très fort celui-là avoir donc
quelqu'un qui est encore qui regarde ça
encore plus près que nous tous pierre
ride directeur général des élections on
est très content que vous soyez là en
direct bonsoir
bonsoir mais ça me fait plaisir d'être
avec vous monsieur monsieur Roy parlons
du taux de participation donc 17h30
45% c'est mieux qu'en 2018 n'est-ce pas
c'est mieux ça peut prendre 5% de plus
quand 2018 ça avait été c'est la même
chose pour le vote par anticipation qui
est à peu près de 18 là on était prêt de
25%, est-ce que la tendance va se
maintenir pour le reste de la soirée
c'est ce que nous verrons après 20h
quand les bureaux vont fermer que le
dépouillement va commencer parce que
évidemment le souhait d'à peu près tout
le monde c'est que le taux augmente par
rapport à la dernière fois là
absolument dans 2018 c'est un taux de 60
un peu plus que 60 et 6%, c'était le
taux le plus faible hormis celui de
décembre 2008 où on avait eu un tour on
était en décembre ça peut se comprendre
de 56 ou 57 %. mais le taux de 85 de
toute personne baisse le des 80%, on ne
connaissant 94 et en 76 mais là on est
vraiment dans le 75 ça descend là
70 très bien monsieur ride la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre vous aviez une poignée de
sa construction où c'était un problème
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé là aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
vous devriez pas non en avoir de
différence c'est sûr que pour le
dépouillement ça serait peut-être un peu
plus long mais dans l'ensemble tous des
routes bien de ça devrait se dérouler
comme ça jusqu'à 20h parlons du
déroulement il y a pas eu de
microche il y a pas eu de pépins majeur
il y a une de vos directrices
dans coin qui a fait un peu de sel
n'est-ce pas ce qu'on a fait un
passeport thème de ça
en fait oui bah il faut savoir que nous
autorisons la prise d'image
sur le lieu de vote parce que même
lorsque les candidats déposent même tout
candidates ça peut être tout candidat ça
circonscription et ça c'est on est
entièrement d'accord avec ça bien sûr ça
fait partie de méga démocratie ça fait
partie de la couverture des élections en
même temps les électeurs de scrutin se
doivent d'assurer le bon déroulement du
vote des électeurs dans leur
circonscriptions ils ont le latitude
pour ça en même temps moi je vous dis
que cet après-midi j'étais un peu
regardé ça je pense que les règles
devront être revu réévaluer parce que
pour son équité là quant à la couverture
médiatique pour tous les candidats et
moi je vous je profite l'occasion
monsieur Roy pour écouter c'est comme
directeur général des élections
générales de la responsabilité et je
suis désolé de la situation de ce matin
et je présente mes excuses au
journaliste qui était présent mais c'est
pas tellement les ben oui vous êtes
gentil pour les journées c'est mais
c'est le chef
on n'a pas eu les images de Gabriel ado
Dubois en train de voter donc une
certaine iniquité là mais vous allez
comme parce que c'était une tradition il
y avait pas de règle écrite ce que je
comprends c'est que vous allez mettre
des règles de dire pour les Chefs vous
avez droit de laisser entrer les
journalistes puis on veut pas câbler la
dame pendant ça sept ans non plus elle
voulait bien faire mais donc c'est mal
tombé
plus plus fondamental c'était une bonne
intention ouais je comprends le vote par
anticipation qui a été important
notamment dans la région de Québec
comment vous comptez ça là ce que vous
le comptez d'un coup tout de suite
depuis quelques minutes
le vote par anticipation va débuter vers
18h ce soir donc dans chaque
circonscription il y a des équipes qui
sont affectées au dépouillement du vote
par anticipation habituellement c'est
les premiers résultats que vous voyez
que qui sont affichés bien sûr en raison
du haut taux de participation on peut
s'attendre à ce qui est des délais moi
je dois vous avouer que d'avoir des
résultats avant 20h45 ce serait
surprenant mais nos équipes vont être à
l'oeuvre pour faire le dépouillement ok
donc tous les premiers résultats pour
qu'on soit clair vous serez qui vont
sortir ça sera le vote par anticipation
oui c'est un vote qui débute déjà et
comme je vous disais en raison du auto
c'est sûr que ça peut prendre un peu
plus de temps donc mais comme je vous
dis faut pas trop compter tant mieux si
des résultats qui sont pas bons mais
disons comptez pas dans 20h45 d'accord
très bien monsieur merci beaucoup de
nous avoir parlé bonne soirée électorale
à vous
mais à vous de même bonne soirée
électoral merci très bien sur le terrain
depuis le début de cette campagne depuis
le 22 août lors du déclenchement nos
caravaniers suivent les chefs Véronique
prince est avec la CAQ alexandre Duval
avec le Parti libéral Valérie Gamache
avec Québec solidaire on a Sébastien
Desrosiers qui est avec le Parti
québécois et Jacques Audré Charbonneau
finalement avec le Parti conservateur
bonsoir On va souvent aller vous voir
bonsoir à vous cinq
Véronique vous êtes au théâtre Capitole
à Québec avec la CAQ j'imagine que dans
la toile je me suis le goût on se disait
bon ben et tant que ça finisse là
effectivement je pense qu'on le sentait
pas mal qu'ils avaient hâte que ça se
termine mais aujourd'hui Monsieur le
goût était quand même de bonne humeur je
dirais on est à Québec devant le
Capitole comme en 2018 mais en 2018
c'était un tout autre contexte à ce
moment-là la CAQ était beaucoup plus en
mode offensif en se disant les 11 côtés
de Québec là on est capable d'aller
chercher tous ceux-là des libéraux et
finalement ils ont réussi à remporter 8
ou 11 en 2018 l'autre contexte c'est
vraiment différent parce que cette
fois-ci on est plus en mode défensif
dans la grande région de Québec
particulièrement Chauveau beau Sud
bosnord Sébastien vient de vous en
parler là beaux ceux des beaux snorges
surtout là je vous dirais que c'est là
où la machine c'est vraiment déployée là
par exemple le provençal le député
sortant de beaux-nord travailler me
dit-on 13 14 heures par jour il y a 21
municipalités dans son comté il est allé
à tous les conseils de ville pour se
faire voir ils ont même engagé un
chauffeur pour le promener partout pour
qu'il puisse travailler en même temps
dans la voiture parce que son adversaire
principal général c'est un conservateur
Olivier Dumet qui est le maire de
Saint-Lambert donc déjà quand même assez
connu dans la région et beau Sud Samuel
Poulin ça a vraiment pas été facile
durant la pandémie je lui avais parlé il
avait été menacée à plusieurs reprises
dès qu'il allait à l'épicerie par
exemple il se faisait parler de la
gestion de la pandémie alors la campagne
n'a pas été facile pour ces deux-là
particulièrement si bien que la CAC a
envoyé beaucoup des députés du personnel
politique pour aller les voir leur
remonter le moral le carrément ils sont
un petit peu plus confiants pour chevaux
je dirais parce que la démographie dans
ce comté là est différente si vous avez
le Lac Beauport un petit peu plus haut
lac de l'âge des gens qui sont plus
aisés
plus éduqué aussi ce côté-là reconnu
pour avoir vraiment deux côtés il a bien
bien distinct et il pense qu'ils vont
être capable d'aller chercher quand même
une majorité peut-être plus importante
qui pense dans Chauveau sinon on va
surveiller Jean leche qui est très serré
me dit-on entre Québec soldat et la
coalition Québec et François Legault
déjà il est en mode je pense que là même
s'il dit on prend rien pour acquis là il
sait que demain il va probablement
revenir au Parlement écouter bien ce
qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
une campagne électorale qu'on le veuille
ou non surtout quand il y a 5 parties
c'est divisé
tout le monde essaye de se distinguer de
s'attaquer on est vu une coupe
m'attaquer cinq semaines là je m'y
attendais mais on a beau s'y attendre
mais je suis resté de bonne humeur
[Rires]
très bien Véronique à tout de suite on
se reparle tout au long de la soirée et
puis on va à Montréal au Théâtre Corona
alexandre Duval bonsoir vous êtes avec
les libéraux Dominique englade c'est
qu'elle a elle a besoin que les libéraux
sortent pour aller voter
c'est vraiment le gros défi Patrice
parce que dans les deux dernières
semaines et demi de campagne à peu près
partout où on allait il y avait très peu
de militants libéraux et c'est pas une
exagération là il y en avait à peine
quelques dizaines à peu près partout où
on passait on l'a remarqué et il y a
quelques reprises on a questionné des
libéraux là-dessus on leur demandait ils
sont où les militants du parti ils sont
où les sympathisants et il y a quelques
tentatives d'explications qui nous ont
été données dans les derniers jours on
lui disait ben vous savez les libéraux
ils sont peut-être plus discrets moyen à
s'afficher publiquement ce qui était
évidemment pas le cas il y a plusieurs
années mais là c'est une des
explications qu'on nous a donnée sauf
que si les libéraux sont plus discrets
dans les rassemblements est-ce que c'est
parce que leurs sentiments
d'appartenance envers le Parti c'était
fritté un petit peu est-ce que Madame
anglais a su les convaincre durant cette
élection de rentrer au bercail de
continuer à soutenir le parti et c'est
le gros défi ce soir parce que Madame
Anglade elle le dit elle veut faire des
gains en dehors de l'île de Montréal
c'est une chose
des châteaux forts à protéger qui sont
menacés qui vont être serrés ce soir la
soirée pour exterminer très tard dans
plusieurs circonscriptions malgré ça
madame Anglade dit écoutez j'ai tout
donné je suis satisfait de la campagne
que j'ai menée de l'énergie que j'y ai
mis essentiellement pour elle les aider
les dés sont jetés et sont électeurs de
faire leur choix ce soir
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir tout donné
dans cette campagne d'avoir mis toutes
les idées de la vente d'avoir été
d'avoir été à l'écoute aussi et d'avoir
été moi-même d'abord et avant tout
d'avoir été moi-même puis donc c'est
pour ça que je suis je vais avec ce
sentiment du devoir du devoir accompli
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup bonne soirée à tout de
suite alors campagne de Dominique
Anglade début laborieux je pense au dire
de tous mais elle Alec elle n'a pas
arrêté jusqu'à la fin non elle est pas
arrêtée puis le débat autour de
l'immigration les gardes de François
Legault lui ont donné de l'énergie à
dominer Anglade ça reste quand même là
c'est à côté des migration l'inclusivité
quelque chose avec lequel elle est à
l'aise pour laquelle d'ailleurs elle a
quitté la coalition Québec à l'époque
c'est vrai que ça lui donne un peu
d'énergie dans sa campagne parce que
l'organisation était déficient des
erreurs dans le cadre financier on
dirait que c'est sujet là lui ont donné
un petit peu de feu et elle a eu un bon
débat à Radio-Canada ce qui lui a aussi
donné une bonne fin de campagne est-ce
que ce sera suffisant pour sauver des
châteaux forts menacés on le verra ce
soir mais clairement pour dominer
qu'englade ça s'annonçait une campagne
difficile ça a été une campagne
difficile est-ce qu'on a été capable à
la fin de leur donner un petit soin à la
campagne c'est ce qu'on va voir ça
Chantal comme dit Alec plus monsieur
Legault parlait d'immigration puis on
avait l'impression madame anglaise
arrivait mieux à définir en fait
savoir au-delà de Madame Anglade qui se
définit sa définit ou ça donne une
raison d'aller voter à des électeurs
libéraux qui peut-être jusqu'à une
semaine du jour se disait ouf ça va pas
bien et puis on est pas très excité par
notre propre partie mais ça c'est une
profonde motivation on a en compte des
électeurs on en a vu en fin de semaine
qui ont apostrophy par exemple Gabriel
n'ado Dubois et est-ce que coller et ce
qui risque d'aider les libéraux ce soir
en tout cas à Montréal c'est pas que les
immigrants s'en vont surtout à Montréal
c'est même pas qui parle pas tous
français c'est de se faire dire qu'ils
travaillent pas
ça quelqu'un qui se fait dire ça et j'en
ai rencontré c'est des gens qui sont
profondément et qui vont s'en aller
voter à cause de ça et peut-être qu'il
serait pas allé il y a cinq ou six jours
et ça ça se traduit Sébastien dans des
circonscriptions très précises là tout
le nord de Montréal Verdun on a parlé
même ça Henri Sainte-Anne la
circonscription de la chef ça peut faire
en tout cas ça peut jouer ça peut bouger
l'aiguille voire même Laval parce que à
Laval la coalition Québec avait des
divisés sur la balle elle a pas mené une
mauvaise campagne elle personnellement
elle a pas fait de gaffe Dominique
anglan mais c'est l'organisation qui
était qui était pas bonne autour d'elle
en fait partie laisser par Philippe
brouillard où il y avait plus de 8
militants nécessairement et pendant une
campagne interne en fait il faut
investir pendant quatre ans dans une vie
militante pour pouvoir arriver à la
finale lors de la campagne électorale et
avoir ses bras pour l'aider ça il avait
ça lui manquait cruellement dans cette
campagne état le 22 août on le vu le
lancement de cette campagne là
un peu d'absence on a l'impression
qu'elle était seule devant son bus de
campagne alors que les autres bon
François Legault c'était ses candidats
dans le nombre mais au moins il avait du
monde
sur cette campagne bah moi j'ai trouvé
très courageux elle conduit un véhicule
qui perd de l'huile depuis un bon moment
il y a plus de boussole et
heureusement pour elle monsieur le Gaule
beaucoup [ __ ] dans la semaine et vous
savez cette idée que des nouveaux
arrivants sont insultés par les paroles
de Monsieur boulet et de monsieur
Legault j'en ai besoin entendu parler à
Québec supérieur le Québec c'est blanc
judéo chrétien pour la français il y a
des gens qui ont été profondément
blessés c'est nous les chercher et pas
seulement des nouveaux arrivants on est
une zone des gens qui on a trouvé ça
inhumé quelque part on a trouvé ça enfin
ça on pense pas qu'en politique
aujourd'hui en 2022 ça puisse encore se
dire ça me fait ça on sent qu'on est
comme on entend des choses de la droite
en Europe c'est exactement ça vous la
droite One Piece
en région c'est tout un défi pour les
libéraux oui parce que même quand on
constate les trois circonscriptions de
la mitigibilité musculaire les candidats
libéraux étaient très en arrière et si
on n'a jamais vu ça habituellement
c'était se libéraux on se dit en 2018 ne
rend pas tes muscle mais on verra mais
les candidats libéraux portent tellement
loin en arrière je postures qu'en région
ça va avoir un impact à ce niveau-là il
y a un candidat un habitué qui était
député dans l'autre circonscription il y
a un bout de temps
exactement moi j'ai trouvé madame
Anglade est parti sans atout là le début
de la campagne aucun atout pas de
programme qui lui permet de se
distinguer plus de militants dans son
propre comté est en arrière il y avait
je disais tantôt d'enverde madame
Mélenchon était mesurée dans certains
sondages à des pilotes des cacahuètes et
elle
un seul atout c'est de distinguer par sa
personnalité l'époque du gouvernement
Couillard c'était ça qu'elle devait
faire et ça ne fonctionnait pas elle
avait beau essayer ça ne fonctionnait
pas mais ça la mayonnaise a pris vers la
fin de la campagne on verra comment tout
ça va se concrétiser en nombre de sièges
avoir Valérie Gama je veux vous êtes au
m TELUS à Montréal avec Québec solidaire
qui a qui avait et qui a de grands
espoirs dans cette campagne
de grands espoirs en fait on veut on
s'est vraiment positionné dans les
derniers jours comme voulant être
peut-être l'opposition officielle on
veut ravir donc ce titre à Dominique
Anglade on est allé faire d'ailleurs
campagne au cours des vraiment tout
dernier jour et même les dernières
heures dans les châteaux forts libéraux
on s'est promené beaucoup à Montréal
dans Maurice Richard dans Verdun dans
vieux et donc ce sont vraiment ces
circonscriptions là qui sont ciblées et
qu'on espère donc ravir au libéraux ce
soir bon c'est même rendu jusqu'à old
parce que là-bas on sent certaines
engouement même si c'est exception qui
est détenue depuis 1981 par les libéraux
donc une circonscription vraiment qui
qui est un château femme riche
Gaudreault d'ailleurs le député libéral
sortante a été élu là sans interruption
depuis 14 ans et c'est vraiment ces
circonscriptions là que l'on que l'on
cible et que l'on espère pouvoir avoir
pour former à cette cette
opposition si elle est là je pense que
vous voyez des images du moment où
Gabriel la dose Dubois est allé s'est
rendu aux autres ce matin est allé ça a
été toute une histoire sur Patrice
aujourd'hui parce que quand on est
arrivé là la directrice de ce côté
offense que nous a dit c'est que Gabriel
a dos du bois aujourd'hui est un
électeur comme les autres et qu'elle
n'avait pas qu'un seul électeur à
s'occuper elle avait à s'occuper des
45000 électeurs de la circonscription de
Gwen alors c'est là qu'elle nous a
empêché au début de prendre des images à
la suite de ça il nous a tenu vraiment à
distance et elle s'est interposée lors
de Gabriel d'ado Dubois et les caméras
de faire de très peu d'images de Gabriel
Nadeau Dubois qui vote et puis là elle
s'est même nous amène pour chasser juste
que sur le trottoir oui elle nous a pour
chasser jusque sur le trottoir devant
donc le bureau scrutin ce que fait en
sorte qu'on n'a pas été en mesure de
faire de même et de presse avec
Gabrielle Nadaud Dubeau aujourd'hui
c'était sa seule apparition devant les
médias et voici le seul commentaire
qu'il a eu le temps de faire à sa sortie
du bureau de vote avant que carrément on
soit chassé de là je le sens
ça c'est très bien passé
j'ai fait mon choix pour la
circonscription de Gouin
bon je sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion d'entendre monsieur
auprès des journalistes alors
je dois dire parce que moi j'ai transpi
au collège également et vraiment c'est
très intéressant de la part de Monsieur
Rey parce que une opération qui devait
prendre un 15 minutes servir aussi à la
démocratie a vraiment mal tourné pour
tout le monde bon ben très bien merci
beaucoup à tout de suite Sébastien
Desrosiers vous êtes à l'Hôtel Mortagne
à Boucherville rassemblement du Parti
québécois
ouais l'ambiance était plutôt bonne
aujourd'hui Patrice avec Paul
Saint-Pierre plat Mondon qui a
l'impression d'avoir mené une bonne
campagne il était heureux au moment
d'aller voter il a fait remarquer que le
ciel était bleu peut-être voulait-il
dire bleu PQ quoi qu'il en soit vous
souviendrez sûrement le jour du
déclenchement de cette déclaration de
Paul Saint-Pierre flamandon qui avait
prédit que le Parti québécois serait
l'équipe Cendrillon du tournoi les
attentes étaient plutôt basses la traîne
dans les intentions de vote monsieur
Sinclair Plamondon était sans doute le
moins connu des chefs et il s'est révélé
d'une certaine façon dans les débats on
a constaté sur le terrain une vague de
sympathie envers lui les gens qui
venaient de féliciter le défi ce soir ce
sera de transformer cette sympathie en
vote sinon le carrosse de Cendrillon
pourrait bien se transformer en
citrouille donc on verra ce soir le taux
de participer sera déterminant
car aujourd'hui notamment dans un arrêt
dans son local électoral de sa
circonscription de Camille Laurin il
leur a dit bon vous pouvez être fier du
travail accompli mais ce n'est pas
terminé à cette heure-ci ils font encore
des appels pour mobiliser les électeurs
monsieur saint-pierre-flamondon a aussi
retrouvé sa famille dans son local
électoral de Camille Laurent aujourd'hui
qui n'a pas vu beaucoup depuis un mois
semblait vous savez l'assemblée fatigué
ces derniers jours on peut le comprendre
après 36 jours sur la route parfois les
émotions prennent le dessus vous allez
le constater dans cet extrait au chef du
PQ s'adresse à ces troupes
ça a été une campagne
très belle
aujourd'hui ce qui nous reste c'est de
d'aller vers les gens puis les inciter à
voter
oui après un marathon comme ça et déjà
laisse aller sa sensibilité et dans des
entrevues ailleurs et il joue à livre
ouvert plus ça a été toute une campagne
pour tous les chefs notamment pour lui
merci beaucoup à tout de suite tour de
table sur cette campagne du PQ parce que
évidemment
au début ça a pris quelques jours mais
l'analyse rapidement et les analyses et
les gens ont vu que il menait une
campagne différente en tout cas dans le
ton ça lui a profité il faudra voir en
effet si ça se transforme en succès dans
l'urne faut mettre les choses en
perspective par contre il partait de
tellement loin que chaque gain était
notable mais au moment où on se parle en
tout cas si on en croit les sondages le
Parti Québécois ne pas le même point
étage qu'il a eu aux élections de 2018
en 2018 c'était 17% pour 10 députés
est-ce que ce soir il va dépasser député
on serait jamais surpris il aura
probablement moins que 10 députés mais
il aura quand même réussi à sauver les
meubles pour sa campagne si le plus que
un ou deux députés comme on pensait au
début de la course vous êtes en deux
mots il y a fait une belle course mais
partait tellement loin qu'à la ligne
d'arrivée est loin des autres j'entends
dans des circonstances plus normale pour
le Parti québécois dans son histoire on
s'en viendrait ne veiller funéraire avec
le genre de score qu'on a dans
l'intention de vote faut pas s'en faire
accroître l'autre problème et c'est à
vérifier c'est que traditionnellement et
en tout cas souvent le vote de
souverainiste dans les intentions de
vote par rapport à l'urne ça a été le
cas du Bloc québécois ça a été le cas du
PQ souvent et sur évaluer et combien de
fois est-ce qu'on se disait au bloc ou
au PQ on va atteindre ou franchir la
barre mythique du 50% et les sondages le
suggérer ça arrivait pas donc faudrait
pas que ce soit le cas ce soir parce
qu'on se retrouverait pas trop loin de
la case départ de la
ce qu'il voulait c'est d'abord sauver le
PQ parce qu'on sait pas dans 4 ans on va
en intro alors entre avoir un député
deux députés ou 10 12 députés ça fait
une grande différence pour la partie
québécois il va y avoir une fatigue
envers la coalition à venir Québec au
moment donné les gens vont chercher une
alternative lui ce qu'il devait garder
s'ils sont partis en vie je pense qu'il
a réussi une campagne qui lui permet de
garder son parti en vie mais dans quel
ampleur on verra mais pour pas le simple
à Mondor c'était l'objectif et il est
atteint un petit mot sur QS parce qu'on
a vu que bien solidaire on parlait de
l'immigration des nouveaux arrivants il
y a une alternative au libéraux
maintenant sur l'île de Montréal qui est
Québec solidaire et au Québec solidaire
on a l'impression qu'on peut capitaliser
aussi sur les gaffes de François Legault
ce n'est pas uniquement les libéraux qui
peuvent en profiter mais que les
nouveaux arrivants qui ont pas le goût
de voter libéral pour être dans
certaines circonscriptions sortir en
masse voter pour QS et donc par leur
permettre de faire des gains cette
dynamique là n'existait pas avant mais
Québec soldat est assez ouvert à
l'immigration comparativement à ce que
par exemple la correction de Québec ou
le Parti québécois propose sauf dans
Québec solidaire le problème c'est la
marque de commerce libéral là on parle
des lecteurs qui ont voté pour Justin
Trudeau il y a un an et qui s'il veut
aller voter et dire je j'en ai qu'on a
dit la première réflexe ce sera pas de
retourner à Québec solidaire ça va être
de retourner vers leur marque de
commerce parce qu'on en parle pas
beaucoup mais même aujourd'hui dans les
intentions de vote fédérales Justin
Trudeau se porte beaucoup mieux Montréal
mais pas seulement Montréal que le parti
idéal du Québec donc il y a un électorat
là qui a voté libéral est encore
contente du Parti libéral fédéral que
réflexes naturels ça favoriserait plus
les libéraux que QS qui a pas vraiment
encore travailler
c'est c'est communauté là de la façon
dont ont besoin évidemment si on attend
la plateaux du Québec au complet pour
que Cuers s'en servir
d'entre nous pour couvrir
vous vous voyez un jour vous une fusion
un accord non ça me semblait possible
impossible ça me semble impossible on se
rappelle que Amir Kader avait tenté le
puis Hélène David aussi mais ça avait
pas fonctionné les membres vous les rien
savoir mais rien et considérait même le
PQ comme un ennemi plus intense que les
autres parties le parti a abattre le
parti abattre parce que le parti de
l'identité nationaliste d'une part mais
d'autre part le nationalisme
identitaire mais d'autre part aussi la
marche aggravir pour devenir un vrai
parti il fallait éliminer le PQ pour
aller chercher ses votes là qui est un
vote un peu progressiste et là ce qui se
passe c'est que la montée de Plamondon
pourrait on ne sait pas encore on va
savoir ce soir mais ça se peut qu'il
soit à la tête d'une troupe de 2
et ça ce qui se les gains qu'il a fait
je regarde des gains sont important dans
certains compter selon les sondages des
sondages et ça pourrait retirer des
votes ou à QS je regarde dans Maurice
Richard là le Parti québécois dernier
sondage doit selon Québec 125 sera
remonté à 20% ce qui était pas du tout
là il y a quelqu'un et c'est à quoi
comme résultat ça comme résultat que
Harun Boisy et Audrey sont face à face
donc Québec soldat et la carte sont face
à face à base de déterminer ce soir donc
le Québec le PQ nuit à Québec solidaire
dans certains comtés c'est clair bon
parce qu'à terme cinq parties pour le
beaucoup souligné à cinq parties
monsieur Legault regarde ça l'opposition
indivisée et c'est une voix Pavil
parfait une campagne électorale
l'environnement d'une campagne M ça va
under mais il y a pris six sept points
alors je pense qu'il faut regarder aussi
des choses froidement une victoire
morale à 11h ce soir ça voudra pas grand
chose et l'histoire vous l'oublier
rapidement je répète depuis 42 ans en
2018 le PQ a connu le pire le pire
résultat de son histoire 17 % et du
siège et ce soir on se demande s'il va
être capable de faire aussi bien que le
pire résultat moi personnellement ne me
demandez pas de croire qu'on va avoir
l'homme victoire quelconque c'est ce
froidement je pense mais est-ce que ça
pourrait pas jouer dans certains comtés
comme Jonquières dans l'Est du Québec
les Îles de la Madeleine puis
dépendamment du vote
à la boule de cristal mais j'aime m'y
penser un peu mais dans certains côtés
peut-être que ça pourrait peut-être
faire un petit peu la différence dans ce
qu'on attend très bien quelqu'un qui a
fait la différence ne serait-ce que dans
la dynamique de cette campagne
électorale c'est le parti conservateur
Jacques Audrey Charbonneau le parti
conservin qui était à deux qui était
même pas à deux en fait il était à 1,7
pour cent la dernière fois tous les
sondages le donnent entre 10 et 14 on
verra ce soir vous êtes au lac de l'âge
d'un chevaux bien sûr ce soir
oui exactement c'est ici qu'aura lieu la
soirée électorale pour le Parti
conservateur Éric Zem vient tout juste
d'arriver avec son conjoint justement
son ami est conseillé Martin du hôtel
ils vont donc passer la soirée dans une
dans une suite ici rejoindre leur
partisans militant un peu plus tard vers
20h 20h30 on attend selon le parti entre
500 et 600 personnes des candidats des
bénévoles également
Eric Diem aujourd'hui est allé voter
justement avec son conjoint il s'est dit
confiant et il est vraiment persuadé que
le Parti conservateur va causer la
surprise aujourd'hui parce que justement
comme vous mentionniez on n'a pas de
points de comparaison pour le Parti
conservateur il a l'impression que les
conservateurs sont discrets et qu'il
pourrait causer la surprise dans
plusieurs circonscriptions il est donné
deuxième dans plusieurs circonscriptions
derrière la CAQ et donc selon lui c'est
un bon signe et il le dit aussi dans les
derniers jours qu'il préparait déjà
l'élection de 2026
donc avec ces deuxièmes positions il
mise là dessus par contre on a vu lors
de cette campagne Éric Zem est capable
de rassembler des foules les militants
sont très motivés or l'élément
fédérateur demeure la contestation aux
mesures sanitaires est-ce que cette
contestation sera toujours présente en
2026 Éric Zem est conscient que c'est un
enjeu pour lui est-ce qu'il réussira à
se faire élire dans Chauveau il y a rien
de sûr actuellement c'est vraiment une
bataille qui va être intéressante à
suivre aujourd'hui et il avait à dire
aujourd'hui que le vote par anticipation
pour lui c'est un bon signe pour son
parti le l'impression que ça pourrait
être payant écoutons-le
notre profil d'électeur est un profil
qui normalement traditionnellement votre
moins et mais cette fois-ci les motiver
donc est-ce que ça peut changer quelque
chose moi je pense que c'est pas le fait
que par exemple le bureau de vote par
anticipation ont connu plus de succès
cette année je pense que c'est pas
étranger à notre montée le fait que
c'est dans la région de Québec une chose
qui est sûr c'est sûr que on a peut-être
pas le même stress que les autres
parties parce qu'on est la seule
formation politique aujourd'hui qui est
certaine de faire mieux que la dernière
fois ça je pense que personne qui peut
contester ça de notre part
effectivement il a tout à fait raison
avec 1,6 il va être il va multiplier par
8 au moins le score de la dernière fois
et vous avez raison il le dit depuis
quelques jours écoutez attendez-vous pas
des miracles déjà où on est c'est un
miracle en soi
voilà très bien merci beaucoup Jacques
Audrey à tout de suite un petit tour
avec Olivier vous êtes à Laval dans un
bureau de vote il y a eu un incident
ou exactement Patrick on se trouve
présentement à l'école Simon Vanier
c'est dans Laval des rapides et ici il y
a au moins une quinzaine de personnes
qui sont repartis sans voter nous a dit
le personnel d'élection donc ces gens-là
sont répartis sans voter parce que leur
nom ne figure pas sur la liste
électorale moi j'ai été témoin j'ai vu
trois personnes repartir qui sont dans
cette situation là ce qu'une dame nous a
expliqué c'est qu'elle a déménagé depuis
la dernière élection qu'elle a amené
toutes les preuves montrant quelle est
sa nouvelle adresse quel est son
ancienne adresse et malgré tout on ne la
trouve nulle part sur la liste
électorale du Québec c'est comme si elle
n'existait pas alors elle a insisté
pendant plusieurs minutes pour pouvoir
voter et finalement elle est repartie
sans pouvoir exercer un son devoir
démocratique alors on a aucune idée de
l'ampleur de la situation combien de
gens au total n'ont pas pu exercer leurs
droits de vote ici à ce bureau de vote
aujourd'hui on a demandé des précisions
élections Québec par courriel on aura
sans doute des explications un petit peu
plus tard dans la soirée alors on se
trouve à Laval des rapides parce que
c'est une circonscription qui sera à
surveiller ce soir en fait toute l'île
de Laval sera surveillée ici en 2018 les
libéraux avaient remporté cinq des six
circonscriptions la CAQ était parvenue à
remporter la circonscription de
Sainte-Rose mais le portrait pourrait
changer ce soir alors dans la valve des
rapides c'est ça le Polo qui se présente
qui se représente pour les libéraux le
seul député libéral sortant à se
présenter pour le Parti libéral du
Québec il va affronter la caquiste
Céline Ethan et c'était très serré
Patrice lors des dernières élections en
2018 il y avait emporté par moins de 300
voix alors ce soir ce sera une bataille
qui sera évidemment à surveiller même
scénario je vous dirai d'environ c'est
la libérale Annabella Monteiro qui va
affronter valerichem smalt de la CAQ et
lors des dernières élections le député
libéral sortant en jean Roussel avait
emporté par moins de 600 voix alors
est-ce que les libéraux vont réussir à
conserver ces circonscriptions si le
vote francophone s'effondre pour les
libéraux ça pourrait basculer dans le
giron de la CAPAC en fait qui
sur le parti idéal dans ma carte et il
est devenu grise parce qu'il y a pas de
résultats qui sont encore rentrés mais
ça me permet de vous présenter les
candidats dans cette circonscription
madame la cueillan Olivier qui se
présente pour le Parti libéral mais
monsieur
planatitisme pour la collection à Québec
pouvoir ravir cette ne devrait pas
pouvoir averse cette circonscription si
on a une qui rester rouge à Laval c'est
bien l'assurance de chomede les autres
sont dans la merde de la clinique oui et
ça fait mal pour les potentiellement ça
va faire mal pour les libéraux là-bas le
Parti libéral recrutait beaucoup
d'anciens conseillers municipaux pour
porter leur couleur pendant cette
campagne électorale ci dans la valve en
disant ils viennent avec une
connaissance du terrain et ils viennent
avec une machine politique qu'on a
peut-être pu la machine qu'on avait mais
en arrière chercher les conseils
municipaux qui sont implantés depuis
longtemps viennent avec des bénévoles
viennent avec une connaissance du
terrain ont chacun leurs organisateurs
locaux on espère pouvoir si on est à
l'arraché dans ce circonscription là
pouvoir aller faire une différence avec
la machine qu'on a recruté à Laval
faudra voir ça va être suffisant
des machines municipales à Laval
qu'est-ce qui lui reste une fois qu'on
franchi l'île Jésus et puis l'île de
Montréal parce que on est on n'est pas
en train de parler de région éloignée ou
une partie libéral a peut-être pas de
racine je dois m'aider c'est en passant
c'est l'ancienne circonscription de
Thomas marker dans son incarnation
libérale
c'est une région les libéraux étaient
avantagée
d'huile dans qui
c'est oui juste la bombe parlait de
plancher historique pour le PQ le
plancher historique
ils seront pas loin de leur plancher
historique parce que sinon il faut
remonter au XIXe siècle pour les
libéraux mais c'est ça qui est en jeu ce
soir aussi pour les libéraux et puis ici
c'est la casse ça veut dire qu'on a une
renouvellement quasi complet du profil
électoral du Québec et si le plancher
les deux parties traditionnelles qui se
sont affrontés pendant des décennies
depuis des libéraux si ils atteignent
leur plancher ça veut dire que le
portrait complètement changé alors il y
a comme une transformation assez
dramatique ils atteignent leur plancher
mais ne veulent pas puis c'est normal on
les comprend ils veulent pas mourir
alors le jeu politique reste à 5 on
parlait de transformation tout à l'heure
il faut revoir dans quelle mesure puis
vous disiez lu jamais au grand jamais il
y aura de fusion à QS c'est à dire que
QS le PQ reste ça veut dire que les
conservateurs seront que les libéraux ne
mourront pas compte tenu du vote à la
fin les libéraux
pourrait être aussi faible soit-il dans
cette élection-là pour être
l'alternative à laxe si jamais la carte
tombe en
disgrâce parce que les différences sont
pas si grandes que ça c'est à dire oui
sur sur l'immigration sur la langue mais
mais ça s'arrange je veux dire le reste
là un parti qui vise à représenter la
classe moyenne qui se présente comme
locomotive économique du Québec
supposons que la casse la carte fasse
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs par ailleurs
la carte
avec 38% des votes c'est le parti qui
prendrait le pouvoir avec le plus faible
pourcentage de vote de l'histoire du
Québec pour un parti majoritaire comme
la dernière fois puis à cinq parties ça
va être ça encore juste pour vous
montrer le défi de du Parti libéral ça
c'est Laval l'île de Montréal
à monter ici ils ont deux
circonscriptions lapinière à la porte
mais au-delà de ça il y a seulement deux
autres circonscriptions au Québec c'est
dans l'Utah ouais à part ça les libéraux
ne sont plus là c'est du Bleu Poudre de
la collection Québec dans les
Laurentides dans la naudière ont monté
régie en esprit aussi à part évidemment
les petits points ici c'est Québec
solidaire dans Sherbrooke donc c'est
tout un défi mais je précise quand même
à 17% 18% du vote ce soir le Parti
libéral reste la position officielle
quand même parce que son 17 18%, mais la
marche mais la marché haute mais sur 17
18% et plus payant qu'un 16 17% pour les
autres parties
la carte qu'on voit là je suis parti
libérale du Québec c'était la carte je
suis parti libéral fédérale avant 2015
il restait rien à l'extérieur ou presque
pas des miettes et tout le monde disait
un changement de paradigme vont toujours
se manger les conservateurs sont assurés
de devenir le nouveau parti naturel du
gouvernement au Canada qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé la marque de commerce libéral est
beaucoup plus forte que la performance
du parti ce soir ou du Parti libéral
fédéral en 2011 quand il est tombé en
troisième place et on l'a vu encore et
encore je vous dis pas que c'est le cas
partout au Canada mais certainement au
Québec ce parti-là a une marque de
commerce qui a des chances de revivre
plus facilement que d'autres et les
parties revivent demander à Jean Charrat
où le Québécois
est au centre de l'échiquier politique
au Québec c'est vrai au Canada aussi les
parties comme la coalition de Québec le
parti libérale du Québec et ratissent
très très large ils ont des chefs ils
ont des passes où ça va moins bien mais
en gros il ratissent un énorme électorat
que des parties qui sont à plus à droite
plus à gauche dans la difficulté
récolter donc la renaissance du Parti
libéral est possible
puis peut-être que le problème qu'on a
aussi on verra le taux de participation
parce que moi je pense que ça c'est une
clientèle qui aura pas voter alors quand
on voit des élections provinciales au
Québec tu as pas 70%, 75 % du monde qui
vont voter ça veut dire qu'il y a des
gens qui restent chez eux et la
clientèle libérale peut être de celle-là
c'est intéressant parce qu'elle pourrait
là nous vous êtes à Québec dans
tâchereau Taschereau c'était bien sûr
une circonscription mythique parce que
Catherine Dorion était là est-ce que il
pourrait avoir des changements on verra
mais ça a voté en tout cas très fort
chez vous
oui c'est à votre fort dans la capitale
nationale si on regarde les cinq
circonscriptions ou les électeurs ont le
plus voté jusqu'à maintenant quatre
d'entre elles c'est justement dans la
région de la Capitale nationale avec
Louis Hébert en tête à 62% ensuite de ça
il y a Montarville à 58 %. ici on se
trouve dans tâches le taux de vote aussi
est élevé le loto de participation est
au tour de 54% Catherine Dorion n'est
plus là mais c'est Étienne Grandmont
pour Québec solidaire qui essaie de
conserver la circonscription on est au
cœur de la ville de Québec au
centre-ville si on regarde un petit peu
plus au nord dans Jean Lesage seul
Zanetti aussi pour Québec solidaire et
cette conserver la circonscription
encore une fois orange mais sinon
partout dans la capitale nationale qu'on
aille dans Port Neuf jusque dans
Charlevoix et au sud de Québec dans
chaudière à palaches tout le reste c'est
coalition à venir Québec c'est bleu
pâles est-ce que les conservateurs vont
réussir une percée en gros la question
ce soir pour la capitale nationale c'est
est-ce que la carte va changer
après les élections alors c'est la
grande question on verra
très bien merci beaucoup vous êtes là
toute la soirée avec nous à Québec on
s'en va tout de suite à Saint-Georges de
Beauce Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc dans la
circonscription de beau-sud donc c'est
là et peut-être même plus qu'à chevaux
on verra mais c'est là qu'on
conservateur pourrait être élu chez vous
deux conservateurs Patrice celui dans
beau sud et celui dans Bose Nord ou pas
en direct de ce soir effectivement de
Saint-Georges devant un bureau de
scrutin parce que les luttes ici vont
être extrêmement intéressantes je
commence par Bose sud on a beaucoup fait
la blague il va falloir rester vigilant
pour voter pour le bon poulain parce que
des poulets il y en a trois Patrice il y
a des blagues Samuel poulain le député
sortant oh oui absolument donc Samuel
poulain de la CAQ il y a Antoine poulain
également du Parti libéral mais lui il a
été parachuté il travaillait dans le
bureau de circonscription de Dominique
Anglade à Montréal et aussi parachuté
ici et il y a Jonathan Poulin ce jeune
avocat de 30 ans qui se présente pour le
Parti conservateur du Québec d'ailleurs
nous plus tard on va se rendre à la
Guadeloupe à son rassemblement pour voir
comment ça se passe et Jonathan Poulin
Patrice oui Jonathan poulet Patrice pour
votre information vous savez il a ben
c'est parti conservateur ils ont apporté
cette tradition de
installé des pancartes en avant des
maisons là-bas lui là il y en a marqué
il en a écoulé 1100 il dit je parlais de
ces organisateurs tantôt il dit on n'a
pas été capable d'en avoir assez mais
finalement ça ça a bien été cette
stratégie là beau ce Nord on va suivre
ça également parce que là il y a le
maire très populaire maire de
Saint-Lambert de l'Ozon qui se présente
contre le provençal de la CAQ encore là
ça va être ça risque d'être très très
serré deux enjeux en bosse Patrick
d'abord Patrice d'abord il y a le fait
que les entreprises manquent de
travailleurs et si le taux de chômage
est à 1,6 % la base c'est le royaume des
PME il a il y en a 500 des entreprises
dans le secteur manufacturier et neuf 9
sur 10 manque de travailleurs alors
pendant la campagne électorale il y a
beaucoup été question ici d'immigration
et il y a aussi la façon dont la
pandémie s'est déroulée il y a un fonds
de conservatisme
vous le savez le ministre de la Santé
sortant Christian Dubé qui était
débarqué en bourse qui avait dit que les
Beaucerons avaient des têtes dures parce
qu'il refusait de se faire vacciner ça a
été l'épicentre aussi de la pandémie
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça tantôt le
maire de Saint-Georges à qui je parlais
Claude Morin disait écoutez là c'est pas
vrai que c'est plein de complotistes ici
mais oui les Beaucerons sont de il m'a
dit des éternels insoumis on a pas on
n'aime pas ça un beau se faire dire quoi
faire
le Parti conservateur a un fantasme en
chaudière à Palace je me permettait
l'expression ce serait d'aller chercher
belle chasse ici à côté s'ils vont
chercher beau snor bossud ils pensent
pouvoir aller chercher Bellechasse aussi
et juste un mot sur la circonscription
d'Éric duem est-ce que peut-être qu'il
regrette monsieur Diem de pas cette
présenter dans Vosges Nord ou dans vos
Sud parce qu'il aurait peut-être eu des
meilleures chances de se faire élire
mais dans cette circonscription à lui
Éric dum Chauveau c'est une
circonscription particulière dans ce
coin ici
avec Beauport très riche Patrick Roy
avait sa maison là au Lac Beauport il a
déménagé depuis alors que plus bas ici
le Red villes peut-être plus classe
moyenne donc ce sera intéressant de voir
comment les gens de cette
circonscription qui s'étend quand même
assez loin au nord le stonam et ainsi de
suite votre rapport ou contre Monsieur
dum ce soir c'est un peu comme il y a
plusieurs circonscriptions comme ça mais
Verdun c'est le même phénomène l'île des
sœurs d'un côté puis Verdun Verdun de
l'autre quartier différent qui peut
voter différemment très très différent
Émilie Nicolas que vous connaissez que
l'on voit notre panel et Christian
Dufour sont avec nous ils vont venir
comme ça au courant de la soirée Émilie
Christian bonsoir
bonsoir alors premier commentaire je
vous laisse le choix vous êtes
c'est libre improvisation libre sur le
thème de la campagne qu'est-ce qui vous
a frappé sur le thème du qu'on est en
train de redessiner la carte électorale
du Québec qu'en pensez-vous Christian
c'est clairement une élection de
transition moi je dirais que ma première
impression c'est que je serai fier
d'être Québécois puis de vivre dans une
grande démocratie je pense qu'il faut le
dire puis quand même l'élément qu'on
sait nouveau là c'est que le taux de
participation semble vraiment plus
important que la dernière fois que c'est
ce que le centrale le directeur général
des élections et ça c'est important moi
au départ ce que je surveillais à la
suite du coup de massue des données de
Statistiques Canada juste quelques jours
avant la campagne sur la chute accélérée
du français à Montréal à Laval je vous
ai ce qu'on va parler du français et de
l'immigration durant cette campagne là
la deuxième chose que je surveillais
c'était le phénomène iridium tel élément
nouveau à la campagne qu'est-ce que ça
allait donner ou est-ce que ça va
aboutir et en fait la deuxième chose au
début que je regardais est-ce que Québec
solidaire va continuer sa montée parce
qu'on sait Quebec solidaire aspirait
aspire encore on n'a pas des résultats à
devenir vraiment comme l'opposition
officielle au gouvernement le groupe je
le dis la campagne s'est déroulée ces
choses-là ont été évoluées ça a été
intéressant mais moi c'était ça mon
premier départ Émilie
c'est sûr que quand on regarde la carte
électorale comme on le fait tout à
l'heure ce qui est ce qui est frappant
c'est les corps entre les centres
urbains bien sûr Montréal mais aussi le
sang de la ville de Québec Sherbrooke et
puis le reste le reste de la carte
électorale actuellement avant avant la
coalition à venir Québec lorsque les
gouvernements formaient le pouvoir
surtout majoritaire il y avait au moins
une bonne représentation sur l'île de
Montréal pour avoir leur chemin vers la
majorité depuis la coalition à venir
Québec c'est plus le cas et je pense que
ça a une influence sur les thèmes qui
sont ressortis durant la campagne
électorale et la façon dont on en a
parlé donc l'histoire du des rats des
villes des rois des champs est très et
très visible sur la carte électorale
peut-être plus que plus que en fait
depuis très longtemps dans l'histoire du
Québec et puis j'ai hâte de voir si la
carte va percer à Montréal si on fait
une bonne campagne ou si on va arriver
avec à la fin de la soirée avec une
carte encore plus divisée entre les
villes et les régions essentiellement à
la fin de la soirée lesquels sont les
conséquences sociales et politiques que
ça va avoir pour le Québec aussi ouais
parce que c'est plus accentuer Christian
le Montréal d'un côté le reste du Québec
de l'autre ça a toujours été comme ça à
l'époque de Duplessis c'était ça ça fait
des décennies que c'est comme ça donc ça
va être intéressant de voir c'est une
élections de transition puis tout le
monde connaît pour acquis en fait là qui
avait 5 parties un parti trop puis que
le PQ c'est fini c'est un peu ça que les
gens pensaient pas si longtemps là il
semble que le PQ c'est pas fini donc on
va se retrouver encore avec cinq parties
comme vous l'avez dit notre mode de
scrutin fonctionne assez bien avec
quelle partie Ottawa ça fait des
décennies en fait que quatre parties ça
marche bien avec cinq parties c'est
moins sûr et c'est clair qu'après
l'élection on sait pas encore mais il
faut se poser le problème des deux
grandes parties francophones de gauche
le PQ est Québec solidaire il fait un
test tout à l'heure a rappelé à quel
point qu'avec soldat vous voulez rien
savoir en fait d'une alliance d'une
fusée avec le PQ mais le problème va se
poser parce que sinon solidaire qui a
frappé quand même un nœud idéologique
durant cette campagne là avec leurs
famoustache taxe orange on ne réagit qui
est un peu trop idéologique et il
voulait à tout prix trouver des super
riches au Québec où il y en avait pas si
les gens de Québec solidaires aspire au
pouvoir il y aura pas d'autres choix que
de penser à saluer parce que notre mode
de scrutin qui est adapté voilà
jamais beaucoup plus tard ce soir
ça va nous amener au sujet du la réforme
du mode de scrutin
inévitablement les gens vont parler de
ça et nous en tout cas on va en parler
ce soir est-ce que c'est illusoire ce
que c'est vraiment une petite clique
juste des intellectuels est-ce que le
gens veulent ça Émilie Christian vous
êtes avec nous je voulais le souligner
vous vous serez là tout au long de la
soirée merci au revoir merci et ce que
je veux souligner mesdames et messieurs
c'est que on se rapproche des résultats
on s'en va aux yeux de la Madeleine il
est 19h et dépoussière les bureaux
là-bas sont fermés ou les madeleineaux
donc ont voté le bureau sont fermés
c'est une heure plus tard là-bas donc je
joins tout de suite Isabelle Larose
bonsoir Isabelle
bonsoir vous avez vous une lutte là je
vais utiliser l'expression du candidat
libéral c'est une lutte de coq là chez
vous avec Jonathan Lapierre et Joël
Arsenault député sortant Jonathan
Lapierre qui est mort
se sont présentés aux urnes non plus en
écouter deux d'entre eux
la tempête le changement climatique
sénégalais on est dans le siège les
premières classes si on peut dire que
ouais c'est important pour moi pour mes
enfants enfin que je pense voter un peu
en ce sens là
l'environnement avec l'ouragan qu'on
vient d'avoir ça nous rattrape un peu là
je pense que ça va être important pour
les pour les pour nos enfants puis nos
petits-enfants peut-être vous le trouvez
plus dur que nous
intéressant merci beaucoup Isabelle à
plus tard aux îles
on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé tout au
long de l'été de la fonderie tout au
long de l'automne de cette campagne
électorale monsieur Legault est allé
chez vous Jean-Marc bonsoir c'est une
campagne qui était tout sauf ennuyant en
tout cas
effectivement il faut dire en fait que
ce qui a ajouté à tout ça c'est que les
deux principaux adversaires en fait on a
ratat et médicaments donc la député
sortante site Québec solidaire émise
laissartérien et Daniel Bernard de la
coalition à venir Québec leurs candidat
ancien député aussi du Parti libéral ici
ne semblait pas s'apprécier beaucoup
faut le dire on le voyait dans les
débats qui avaient lieu ici il y a même
une plainte officielle déposée directeur
général des élections de la part de
Québec solidaire on reprochait aux
candidats de la CAQ de cette présentée
au vote par anticipation d'avoir serré
des mains donc on le sentait vraiment
dans le ton et vous l'avez dit quand
François Legault s'est présenté ici dans
les derniers jours de la campagne
électorale ça a vraiment fait en sorte
de raviver ce débat ce duel en T2
candidats mais aussi en même temps entre
des idées qui s'opposent en lien avec la
fonderie orne c'est ça dont on a
beaucoup parlé pendant la campagne
électorale cette entreprise qui peut
émettre davantage d'arsenic donc jusqu'à
100 nanogrammes dans l'air alors que la
norme C3 on a Québec solidaire d'un côté
donc avec la députée actuelle qui a
beaucoup militaire pour que cette norme
soit respecté et d'un autre côté on a la
CAQ qui est allé d'un juste milieu si on
veut en fait on a dit à l'entreprise
vous pouvez émettre jusqu'à 15 donc 5
fois la norme mais on veut que vous
baissiez davantage pour une question de
santé au niveau de la population parce
qu'il était démontré qu'il y avait des
quatre cancers du poumon notamment donc
c'est devenu en quelque sorte ça un
enjeu électoral en fait c'est le
principal enjeu à Rouen Noranda mais il
faut pas oublier aussi les gens du
thémisquemment évidemment mais c'est
clair maintenant restez à avoir est-ce
que ça aura un impact sur le taux de
participation aussi ici tout à fait
monsieur LEGO a dit ça sera aux gens de
décider on verra donc mais c'est
effectivement merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
c'est effectivement quelque chose que le
candidat de la CAQ Manon je me tourne
vers vous soit l'ancien député libéral
parce qu'à Rouen les gens qui sont loin
de ça
comme je suis les gens de Montréal
votaient ça serait certainement le pas
le même résultat que les gens de Rouen
c'est pas clair que tout le monde veut
que ça ferme
mais c'est pas juste ça c'est que tout à
fait mais sauf que dans le fond la
fonderie on a déjà voir d'abord été une
mine et puis 100 ans donc il y a eu des
impacts depuis 20 ans c'est une fonderie
où on fait beaucoup d'impact sur
l'environnement mais on peut pas régler
ça en criant ciseau et moi ce que je
trouve dommage c'est comment le dossier
est devenu viscéral et polarisé et c'est
pas c'est pas des choses qui peuvent se
décider ou se réveiller rapidement créer
un ciseau il faut avoir un certain
rationnel mais je pense que moi peu
importe le résultat ce soir la fonderie
devra faire des ajustements mais il
faudra donner du temps mais il y aura
quelque chose à adresser vous êtes fait
40 ans là on peut pas en deux ans ou en
une année arrivé à trois ou même à 15
nanogrammes scientifique je peux pas
vous dire si c'est ça mais moi ce que je
ça fait au-dessus de 20 ans que ça se
passe et dans les dernières années c'est
devenu un enjeu à ou un oranda mais
écoutez les gens vivent à côté de la
fonderie depuis il y a des gens qui sont
nés et deuxième troisième génération à
côté de la fonderie alors mais moi je
dis oui faut que ça serait oui il faut
tendre améliorer le score mais il faut
avoir un certain rationnel et lorsqu'on
constate quand c'est une campagne
électorale mais c'est pas l'arrivée et
je pose sur qu'on a les meilleurs
suggestions et tout le monde des semble
découvrir ça la classe politique alors
que ça fait 45 ans qu'on connaît qu'on
sait qu'il y a des rapports il y a un
peu peut-être d'hypocrisie collective
là-dedans là écoutez c'est une
raffinerie c'était tout de même avant
maintenant on importe les métaux de
l'extérieur et de très loin et on
raffine là c'est pas nouveau moi je suis
étonné que le lac à Sisco là-bas ça fait
longtemps qu'on sait qu'il y a pas un
poisson peut faire 10 minutes je crois
que ça va mieux là
c'est pas nouveau mais sa pop-up comme
ça elle avait une campagne électorale
grand je dirais à la députée de Québec
solidaire il faut le dire oui grâce
c'est rare que que je souligne ça mais
on n'a pas besoin nécessairement de
s'excuser auprès des journalistes pour
ce qui est arrivé dans le bureau de vote
de Gouin mais la fonderie journalistique
énorme que qui a été fait également bon
rapidement sur la fonderie là je dis que
c'est la dernière fonderie au Canada en
terme de de stratégie nationale on parle
de garder nos entreprises ici notre pote
avoir l'exportation d'avoir tout à
l'étranger ça fait partie du débat mais
c'est aussi au gouvernement de trouver
une manière que les gens qui vivent près
de la fonderie est une santé qui soit
acceptable on est plus entendre plus si
on a créé par exemple à l'abbaye pour le
glissement de terrain programme pour
acheter les maisons permettre aux gens
de déménager ce qu'on peut imaginer
quelque chose pour rien on est rendu là
oui la fonderie est importante mais un
moment donné on est plus non plus dans
des normes des années 60 alors c'est
vrai que les gouvernements après la
campagne électorale faudrait que les
gouvernements locaux et provinciaux s'y
attelle parce que ça va rester un débat
important vous êtes un épi dans le temps
de Germinal
très bien on s'en va moi vous me parliez
de Laval chouchou pour moi j'en ai
plusieurs en fait j'ai Sherbrooke
Saint-François côté j'ai hâte vraiment
d'avoir les premiers résultats dans
Sherbrooke et de Saint-François Brigitte
bonsoir Saint-François
qui est-ce qui a lancé sa campagne là
dans un vignoble c'est très beau le 22
août le dernier j'espère faire un gain
là avec l'ancienne directrice de la
santé publique une médecin Sherbrooke
une grosse bataille également ça va être
très intéressant chez vous
ouais mon petit doigt me dit ce soir que
vous allez avoir le regard tourné vers
Sherbrooke assez souvent vous l'avez dit
du côté de Saint-François c'est une
lutte qui est serrée vous avez là la CAQ
avec Geneviève Weber qui est la député
sortante qui a été élu en 2018 et là le
Québec solder qui est arrivé avec une
candidate d'une personnalité publique
très connue ici très impliqué dans la
région docteur Mélissa généreux qui on
le sait s'est impliqué au moment de la
tragédie de Lac-Mégantic qui a été
impliquée au moment de la pandémie
également directrice de la santé
publique en esterie donc évidemment ce
sera une lutte très serrée du côté de
Saint-François et quand on regarde du
côté de Sherbrooke ici c'est Christine
Labrit de Québec solder qui est la
député sortante et là ben François
Legault a misé sur Caroline
Saint-Hilaire pour tenter de ravir le
siège Caroline Saint-Hilaire ancienne
mairesse donc de Longueuil pendant 8 ans
elle a déjà été député blociste
également du côté de la Chambre des
communes donc Caroline Saint-Hilaire les
spécialistes disaient en début de
campagne oui elle est connue pour
François Legault est-elle connue des
sherbroquois belle la réponse est dans
l'urne dans les urnes on le saura un peu
plus tard à savoir ce Caroline
Saint-Hilaire pour la carte a réussi
vraiment à se faire connaître des chers
bocaux sur le terrain Christine
l'abrielle qui a toujours dit pendant
qu'elle faisait campagne et lorsqu'elle
a été élue en 2018 rappelez-vous ça a
été une surprise elle qui a défait donc
Luc Fortin en 2018 du parti libérale
elle a dit je sens que je suis un
caillou pour la CAQ ici à Sherbrooke
parce qu'il y a juste Christine Labrit
ici pour Québec solidaire tout autour ce
sont des députés de la CAQ qui avait été
en 2018 donc effectivement lutte très
serré chez nous autant du côté de
Saint-François que du côté de Sherbrooke
et je vous dirais que tout au long de
cette campagne on a beaucoup beaucoup
parlé de la santé parce que bon on a des
résidences privées pour un nez qui ont
fermé il y a des médecins de l'urgence
qui sont sortis pour réclamer des
changements dans le système de santé
alors ça là c'est sujet là ont alimenté
le débat de cette campagne électorale on
a hâte comme vous de voir quel sera le
résultat ce soir dans Sherbrooke et
Saint-François et ailleurs également en
Estrie on va aller très souvent vous
voir et le simple fait d'avoir choisi
Caroline Saint-Hilaire au kiabète
maintenant en Estrie mais de la part de
la CAQ ça montrait que toutes les
circonscriptions qui ne leur
appartenaient pas on voulait les ravir
là on prenait au sérieux chaque lutte là
que ça soit dans l'Est du Québec on va
en parler dans une seconde ou chez vous
un esprit il leur en manque une
exactement très bien merci beaucoup au
revoir oui Sébastien ben c'est clair
qu'on le voit sur la carte et je vous
promets je ne vais utiliser l'expression
village gaulois qu'une seule fois
non plus mais ça illustre Sherbrooke à
quel point c'est un village gaulois
entouré de bleu poudre de la coalition
Québec la circonscription dont on
parlait qui est juste à côté c'est
François aussi dans la merde de Québec
solidaire c'est de circonscription et il
est intéressant aussi à cause du tissu
social parce que juste ici ça borde la
ville de Sherbrooke donc plusieurs bains
mais ici c'est beaucoup plus rural alors
ce sera intéressant de voir comment les
gens dans cette circonscription là de
saint François décide de voter qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de
similaire entre Sherbrooke et
Rouyn-Noranda dont on a parlé au cours
des dernières minutes des villes où il y
a des universités donc Québec solidaire
mise beaucoup sur le vote sur les campus
il y a un fantasme je vais vous livrer
les fantasmes des parties tout au long
de la soirée quand tu es sur moi un
fantasme ça fait deux
le fantasme de Québec solidaire ce
serait hall ce soir Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois est allé à Old en fin de campagne
électorale on pense avoir un désespoir
il y a l'Université du Québec en
Outaouais dans cette région là aussi
donc le fil conducteur des Persé si on
veut de Québec solidaire à l'extérieur
de l'île de Montréal c'est souvent qu'il
y a des villes universitaires là on me
demande de vous faire voyager Patrice
alors je vais vous faire voyager on va
s'en aller dans ma région chouchou c'est
pas moi qui le veut là c'est la
réalisation en régie donc le
gaspéziers mais vous voyez aussi en haut
la côte nord cette région là avec les
Îles de la Madeleine je vous le rappelle
9 circonscriptions 8 appartiennent aux
parties québécois dont celle-ci de
Matane matapedia et on y va à Matane
merci Sébastien Jean-François Deschamps
vous êtes amateur la circonscription
évidemment de Pascal Bérubé monsieur
Legault jour 2 ou 3 de la campagne avait
dit à son candidat qui se présente comme
dérubé avait dit on va lui donner toute
une raide ça donnait le temps de cette
campagne
effectivement effectivement le
présentement je me trouve dans la salle
où vont se rencontrer les partisans de
Pascal Bérubé c'est vite de présentement
mais probablement que ça va être bien
rempli on va voir qui va donner une
raide à qui alors on a bien l'intention
de participer à tout ça ou en tout cas
en témoigner mais parce que le Bérubé il
faut le rappeler a gagné en 2018 avec
17000 voix de majorité ce qui en dit
long sur la zone sur comment les gens
ici aiment leur ou apprécie leur
candidat pékistes donc ça a pas été une
disons une campagne très très
mouvementée ici dans ma tante Matapédia
si on regarde tout ce qui s'est passé
autour parce que tous les chefs des
grands partis sont venus à Rimouski
Gaspé Bonaventure aux îles ils sont
venus et après qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
ils sont revenus après mais il y a pas
eu beaucoup de visites dans ma tan m'a
tapédia donc peut-être Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon qui est venu il y a quelques
jours à Sainte-Flavie mais il y a eu
quand même une petite chose là qui a été
bien excitante ici qui a été
intéressante pour les journalistes que
nous sommes c'est lorsque le candidat
libéral s'est fait rejeter sa
candidature par le directeur de scrutin
et bien les libéraux provinciaux ont
déployé l'artillerie lourde pour le
défendre et finalement il a gagné
plusieurs observateurs disent que cette
histoire fera jurisprudence alors
c'était surveillé dans dans 4 ans oui il
a gagné sa présence dans le concours
mais non pas le comté évidemment et dans
Du Plessis voilà du Plessis il y a deux
zinous d'ailleurs ce soir il y a 9
candidats candidates qui proviennent des
Premières nations dont deux Inno dans Du
Plessis
oui c'est une première du Plessis faut
le dire c'est dans le coin de cette île
et la base contenant deux Zino c'est une
première à ce qu'on nous dit dans ce
coin-là une autre première alors
peut-être est-ce que le Parti québécois
sera conservé la circonscription de
Duplessis on le sait que le PQ est au
pouvoir là-bas depuis
1965 alors c'est peut-être un coin à
surveiller aussi c'est facile merci
beaucoup à tout de suite c'est fascinant
de voir la dernière fois en 2018 comment
la vague kakis c'était arrêté à Rimouski
et à l'autre bord à Tadoussac
et le piqûre garder tous les du Québec
oui par la peau des dents un peu aussi
par la peau de la Madeleine par quoi
47 voix de mémoire 15 voix pour Gasper
ça va chauffer pas mal mais oui on avait
réussi à tenir le fort et si encore un
Parti québécois compétitif entre
guillemets ce soir tu peux espérer
garder certains compter c'est parce que
là ça résister la dernière fois
je pense pas que parce que bébé soit
particulièrement inquiet ce soir mais
ailleurs ailleurs il va avoir des luttes
très intéressantes à suivre oui c'est
intéressant Sébastien prend le vous
montrer depuis le début c'est quand même
une forteresse acquise par des mines
marges gaspées passer le lendemain qu'on
l'avait eu le soir de l'élection Mégane
me lancement avait perdu l'élection
candidats du Parti québécois il y a eu
un comptage judiciaire dans Gaspé de
spécial ici et finalement il a gagné
deux noms en particulier sa dixième
circonscription ce soir mais quand vous
dites que ça s'arrête net fret sec c'est
ça que vous avez dit pas tout à fait
mais ça voulait dire on comprend sens
vous voyez la la coalition à venir
Québec ici est arrivée du lootémies
squata ensuite au cours du Sud et tout
le Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean et Bleu
Poudre sauf la circonscription de
Jonquières qui à part dans l'Est là est
une des deux circonscriptions que le
Parti québécois avait gardé en 2018
l'autre étant Joliette Joliette merci de
robot pour moi voilà mais les 8 autres
sont dans le Québec donc le Parti
québécois plus gros dans cette dans
cette belle région de l'Est du Québec
notamment
Rimouski madame Matapédia Gaspé
Bonaventure René Lévesque du Plessis
est-ce que vous voyez pas les Îles de la
Madeleine de ce côté-là et on va y aller
à Saguenay parce que s'il fallait au
terme la soirée que le Parti québécois
n'est pas de représentant au Saguenay
Jean-François Coulomb bonsoir ça serait
une première bonsoir oui une première en
50 ans en fait on est dans le dernier
bastion pékiste dans la région et une
chose certes de certaines ce soir
Patrice et qui aura un nouveau ou une
nouvelle député à Jonquières puisque le
député sortant Sylvain Gaudreault ne se
représente pas il était député ici
depuis 15 ans et si le Parti québécois
devait perdre Jonquières et ne faire
aucun gain ailleurs dans la région mais
il y aurait pas de députés pékistes pour
la première fois depuis 50 ans en fait
depuis 1973 le Parti québécois a
toujours fait lire au moins un député
dans la région plus près de nous en 2012
il y a 10 ans les cinq circonscriptions
ont été il en restait trois en 2014 une
en 2018 on verra ce qui va se passer ici
ce soir pour ravir Jonquière la
coalition à venir Québec mise sur
Yannick Gagnon c'est le directeur du
patro de Jonquières c'est un centre de
loisirs communautaire pour les jeunes
bien connus ici et dont la rénovation
avait été un enjeu important lors de
l'élection de 2018 d'ailleurs François
Legault était venu à ce moment-là au pas
trop de Jonquières rencontré Yannick
Gagnon faut croire qu'il y a eu des
atomes crochus entre les deux le Parti
québécois mise sur Caroline Dubé elle
est la directrice du bureau du député
bloquiste de Jonquières Mario Simard
faudra aussi surveiller le Parti
conservateur qui a voulu faire de la
relance du projet de Gmail Québec la
question de l'urne dans la région et
donc c'est une circonscription très
convoitée la preuve le Premier ministre
sortant François Legault a déclenché
officiellement la campagne électorale
ici même le 28 août dernier et le chef
du Parti québécois Paul Saint-Pierre de
La Mondon a terminé sa campagne
électorale à Jonquières hier après-midi
il m'a d'ailleurs accordé une entrevue
pour Allemagne des derniers entrevues
qu'il a accordé lors de cette campagne
alors ça va être très intéressant de
surveiller ce qui va se passer ici ce
soir et qu'elle sera la réaction du
Parti québécois s'il devait perdre cette
circonscription oui la symbolique est
quand même très forte au Saguenay s'il y
avait pas de piquer sa voix avoir les
résultats je vous le rappelle mesdames
et messieurs dans 40 minutes on aura les
ça sera la fermeture des bureaux du
scrutin on aura les premiers résultats
Sébastien la carte les tableaux on va
aller à vitesse grand V vitesse grand V
pour vous livrer de façon la plus claire
possible tous les résultats et la carte
de Sébastien va se colorer selon les les
désirs de la population dans chaque
circonscription et c'est vous qui
décidez on a beaucoup parlé nous tous
les politiciens ont beaucoup parlé
pendant 36 jours mais aujourd'hui
c'était la population qui elle parlait
on verra le résultat donc à partir de
maintenant en principe c'est le vote par
anticipation qui est dépouillé en
premier donc on devrait quand même avoir
des résultats assez rapidement mais le
DG tout à l'heure vous a dit 20h45 il
m'a répété deux fois 20h45
qu'on aurait mais qu'on arrive
du vote participation mais il a dit mais
en même temps on commence à 6h à compter
donc mais comme le vote par anticipation
a été historique extrêmement élevé on
devrait avoir quand même beaucoup de
résultats assez rapidement il y a 24%
des Québécois qui ont voté mais comme
100% n'auront pas voter en réalité on a
un électeur sur trois qui sait déjà
prononcé dans le vote par anticipation
donc ça va donner quand même une
indication de l'allure de la soirée très
bien ça va coup de joie
une circonscription qui vote peu
à 17h30 je crois que c'était vous aviez
le pire score
oui un taux de participation qui est
historiquement mais ça pourrait changer
Patrice cette année parce qu'il y a deux
candidats autochtones qui créent
énormément d'intérêts dans leur
communauté respective je voulais
présente rapidement mettez la break
saganage d'abord de Québec solidaire qui
est la fille de l'ancien député Romeo
saganache une militante crie très connu
dans sa communauté et qui affront donc
tous nous n'appartooc du Parti libéral
du Québec un Inno qui est l'ancien maire
de coup de jouaque une autre figure très
connue ici dans sa communauté et dans la
circonscription deux candidats donc qui
vont tenter de renverser cette tendance
là d'un désintérêt envers la politique
provinciale j'ai les chiffres ici en
2018 lors du dernier scrutin dans
l'ensemble de la circonscription d'une
Gava on comptait environ 30% d'un taux
de participation mais dans les
communautés inoïdes écrit là c'est un
taux qui descendait sous la barre des
20% et parfois sous la barre des 15%
dans la majorité des communauté un des
intérêts qui est dû à plusieurs facteurs
mais notamment la barrière de la langue
ou le cri les noukitoute et prédominant
suivi de l'anglais donc tous les
messages de campagne en français ont
peut-être un peu plus de mal à se rendre
ici ensemble ici au nord et il y a aussi
un certain sentiment de ne pas être bien
représenté à l'Assemblée nationale au
moins je suis une partie de l'électorale
autochtone ici il voudrait un député qui
vient de leur communauté qui comprend
leur réalité donc ces deux
candidatures-là qui suscitent énormément
d'intérêt dans les communautés
autochtones qui représentent environ 65%
pour le dire de l'électorat de la
circonscription d'une Gava c'est de loin
la proportion des lecteurs autochtones
la plus élevée partout dans parmi les
autres circonscriptions de la province
le reste de l'électorat à l'automne est
concentré plus au sud de la
circonscription dans le territoire de la
Baie James donc à Shibu Gamo le Bel sur
kévillon Chapet c'est dans ce territoire
là que les autres candidats sont
concentrés leurs efforts de campagne il
y a notamment Denis Lamotte une
coalition à venir Québec qui veut
briguer un second mandat qui avait été
élu en 2018 avec seulement 46 voix
d'avance sur le Parti québécois le Parti
québécois qui a nommé cette année
Christine mort une ancienne députée
fédérale du NPD dans la circonscription
d'habitivité musculaire et finalement
Nancy a lancé du Parti conservateur du
Québec qui a donné une campagne très
discrète que pratiquement pas été
visible sur le terrain donc vraiment
Patrice la question ce soir qui va être
déterminante pour le vote ici dans Gava
pour les résultats dans Gama c'est
est-ce que les communautés autochtones
vont sortir voter c'est ce qu'on va
suivre ce soir c'est exactement la
question que je voulais poser à Manon
merci beaucoup à m'annoncer parce que
oui ils veulent davantage représentés
pour les comprend tout à fait en même
temps ils ne vont pas beaucoup voter
effectivement et ça m'étonne toujours de
voir parce que là vous avez deux
candidats un du côté de coup de jouet
une du côté droit ça devrait susciter
l'intérêt du vote mais ce qu'il faut se
rappeler lorsque ont été voté l'année
passée pour leur grand chef madame
mendygone masti 35% de taux de
participation alors je pense pour que ce
soit il va avoir un SIO taux de
participation malheureusement mais moi
je trouve ça bien qu'au moins les gens
veulent participer et un gavotte depuis
les dernières années les communautés
crient toltones et une nuitée prennent
plus de place mais votre moins donc ça
fait un tour de participation on a plus
bas possible c'est comme un lamp
processus de tendre la main puis
peut-être dans trois quatre élections ça
va être la dynamique va être différents
il faut savoir que la loi électorale
permet des bureaux de vote itinérant
adaptés au
mais dans les différentes communautés un
peu plus que ceci est permis et même
auprès des sites miniers ou dans
différents secteurs éloignés de la
région donc moi je croyais que la charge
pouvait avoir un effet négatif mais on
me dit que c'est pas nécessairement il y
a des particuliers Québec solidaire
déployé une organisatrice que 75 ans 75
ans l'organisatrice de Québec solidaire
qui est à l'origine des victoires de
Vincent maréchal et americadia dans le
temps donc on met le paquet pour QS dans
cette sessions sont allés il faut savoir
aussi que Monsieur le goût est venu déjà
dans la dernière année dans le dernier
Mado 5 fois Monsieur Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois est venu au début où il est venu
au début de la campagne madame vous avez
vu en fin de semaine les gestes
questionnaient pourquoi avoir coup de
jouet mais si vous voulez susciter
l'intérêt faut aller en région même si
c'est relativement peu de vote très bien
on va aller on fait un saut éclair à
Gatineau Rosalie Saint-Clair c'est la
circonscription de Hall qu'on surveille
ouais circonscription qui libérale
depuis plusieurs années qui a été
libérale depuis 1956 outre une percée du
Parti québécois 1976 c'est Maryse
Godreau qui détient la circonscription
depuis 2008 et je vous le rappelle lors
des dernières élections en 2018 la CAQ
qui avait fait une percée en Outaouais
qui avait remporté trois des cinq
circonscriptions alors hall certainement
qu'on va la surveiller au courant de la
soirée ça a été le cas pendant toute la
campagne on sait qu'en outaoui il y a la
proximité avec l'Ontario donc il y a eu
la question de la main d'oeuvre dans le
milieu de la santé c'est travailleurs de
la santé qui vont en Ontario pour
travailler avoir de meilleurs salaires
de meilleures conditions salariales donc
ça a été un des enjeux discutés en
Outaouais alors voilà circonscription de
haul qui appartient au parti libérale du
Québec qui sera à surveiller
certainement est-ce que cette
circonscription passera du rouge au bleu
ce sera suivra avec les résultats ce
soir déjà que de poser la question c'est
déjà c'est déjà quelque chose là parce
que ne bougez pas pendant très longtemps
l'outaway pour les libérer ou bien
absolument
2018 donc pendant toute la campagne les
yeux ont vraiment été rêvé sur la
circonscription de all laka qui a
présenté sa candidature Tremblay qui
était président du syndicat des
enseignants de l'outawa alors quand même
un visage connu dans la région très bien
merci à plus tard au revoir oui luttaway
ils sont tous allés évidemment mais
c'est déjà qu'on en parle comme un autre
il y avait une première percée dans la
nature une deuxième dans la mine de tout
le monde à la fois la coalition Québec
solidaire circonscription de Hall ici
contient qu'on en parle pas parce qu'on
pense que André Fortin est très bien
assis sur cette circonscription là il
devrait être élu mais dans un il va y
avoir une bataille et je définis juste
pour le bénéfice de tout le monde le mot
fantasme que j'utilise c'est si ça va
très très très bien pour Québec
solidaire ce soir donc ils sont vraiment
en gains ils pensent peut-être avoir une
chance dans elle mais la carte aussi les
libéraux la beauté de la chose
savez-vous quoi Sébastien on va voir les
vrais chiffres dans 30 minutes donc on
va passer du fantasme à la réalité
c'est ce que tout le monde veut très
bien
très bien alors dans je vous avertis
tout de suite que dans oui 31 minutes
les bureaux ferment dans quelques
minutes on va accueillir les
téléspectateurs de Radio-Canada alors
les gens RD oui vous allez réentendre
certaines choses mais on va essayer de
les dire autrement Sébastien plein de
mots dans sa besace et on est en forme
on a réchauffé le plateau ça va être une
très belle soirée électorale moi je peux
vous dire que j'ai très très hâte au
premier résultat est-ce que ça sera les
idées de la Madeleine le vent du large
souvent ça arrive en premier mais ce
n'est pas à chaque fois les îles alors
on se retrouve l'autre côté de ceci
devenir voter peu importe pour qu'elle
parte on va donner ma voix à une
personne qui va être en place pour nous
représenter et c'est notre
responsabilité parce que c'est important
pour la démocratie est-ce que c'est
important pour faire notre comme tout le
monde dit la fameuse classique parce que
c'est notre devoirs
pour toutes les générations pour bâtir
le futur
avec votre fille oui en même temps on
parle c'est quoi ça voter c'est notre
droit fondamental puis je pense que dans
une démocratie forte exacer notre droit
de vote ben c'est signe que la
démocratie est en santé on a devoir les
résultats
[Musique]
ce sont dans notre histoire des soirées
importantes
[Musique]
les électeurs de chez nous mon ordre de
leur confiance et le confinement de
présenter leurs intérêts
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a plus de maintenant ou jamais ce
soir nous devons dire c'est maintenant
que nous deviendrons maître chez nous
Québec d'abord c'est un appel à la
coopération de tous les Québécois pour
relancer le Québec sur la voie du vrai
progrès
l'avenir de notre pays se trouvant en
jeu nous sommes bien équipés pour
relever ce défi et pour faire face aux
priorités du Québec
j'ai jamais pensé que je pouvais être
aussi fier de Québécois que ce soit
[Applaudissements]
sans femme relevons ce Québec pour
qu'elle nous sommes tellement attachés
abordons ce nouveau chapitre de notre
histoire
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi réaliser leurs aspirations
aujourd'hui au Québec on s'est donné un
gouvernement du 21e siècle nous sommes
prêts pour la première fois le
gouvernement du Québec sera dirigé par
une femme
enfin nous pouvons pour réussir nous
allons tout réussir
aujourd'hui
on a marqué l'histoire
[Musique]
c'est juste un mot à vous de lire
bon on repart les compteurs à zéro
et on est à un moment décisif c'est
l'élection de la dernière chance si vous
êtes en train de faire l'histoire quel
avenir pour notre destin
nous vivons la 43e élection générale au
Québec ces joutes électorales sont des
repères des marqueurs dans l'histoire
les cinq chefs vous ont présenté des
visions très différentes ils ont plaidé
ils ont débattu ici même ils ont
beaucoup parlé depuis 36 jours ce soir
ils attendent votre réponse bienvenue à
votre soirée électorale
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice Roy et toute l'équipe de
l'information de Radio-Canada très
heureux de vous accueillir encore une
fois dans l'atrium de cette nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada sur notre
nouvelle place publique Sébastien
Beauvais bonsoir
oui on se le cachera pas les gens disent
puis on a parlé à tous les jours de
cette campagne on sait bien qui va
gagner il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
croyait savoir que ce sont pas avérés
dans cette campagne il y a quand même eu
des surprises et il reste des questions
fort importantes il reste des questions
à faire importantes notamment de savoir
qui sera l'opposition qui pourrait être
l'opposition officielle à partir du
moment où on pense que la coalition
Québec va l'emporter mais en même temps
c'est vous qui dessinez la carte de qui
coloriait la carte électorale au Québec
donc le choix des Québécois aujourd'hui
ils se sont exprimés depuis 36 jours
vous nous avez beaucoup entendu nous
parler les politiciens parler mais
aujourd'hui c'était aux gens de
s'exprimer Chantal Hébert allait
castonguet bonsoir merci d'être ici avec
nous
Chantal qu'est-ce que vous allez
surveiller ce soir en particulier
cinq parties est-ce qu'il y a cinq chefs
à l'Assemblée nationale je pense que on
n'échappe pas cette question là surtout
pour des parties qui auront pas
nécessairement des immenses cocus c'est
donc si écrase leur cou ce soir pas
beaucoup de gens qui pourraient leur
céder un siège pour qu'ils s'essaye pour
rentrer à l'Assemblée nationale et pour
un parti je pense en particulier aux
parties conservateur particulier
nationale c'est une condition presque
essentielle pour pouvoir bâtir un
meilleur résultat dans quatre ans et
c'est rare il faut le souligner comme
vous dites que trois des cinq chefs
d'abord c'est rare que cinq chefs
1976 il y avait cinq parties mais pas
vraiment c'est la première fois depuis
Mathusalem oh c'est rare que trois des
cinq peuvent ne pas entrer bref
c'est en fait même au fédéral on sait
pas vraiment posé de questions sur Jack
meeting Elizabeth May ces gens là
passaient dans leur circonscription
c'est ça parle c'est un signe d'État au
Québec on la carte électorale continue
de bouger en 2018 quand on était pas sur
le même plateau c'était moins beau
lac passe mais est-ce que on va revenir
à la normale les libéraux le Parti
québécois c'est pas ça qui s'est passé
et ça explique comment on a cette
dynamique électorale vraiment
particulière très bien Alec vous
surveillez quoi ce soir beaucoup
beaucoup de batailles régionales
intéressantes dans le bas du fleuve en
Gaspésie en esprit l'île de Montréal
l'île de Montréal va avoir des batailles
intéressantes c'est pas souvent le cas
Laval aussi figé souvent depuis des
décennies lavalles pourraient bouger ce
soir en outai ouais pour y avoir des des
surprises à rouen-noranda ça va être
surveillé donc à peu près tout le Québec
doit être à surveiller pour des raisons
différentes et ce qui va être décidé ce
soir on va avoir un impact pendant les
quatre prochaines années la dynamique
des parties un en croissance un à
décroissance est-ce qu'un chef est là ou
non il y a un impact Assemblée nationale
et sur la dynamique du paysage politique
québécois et c'est les élections où on
tranche dynamique là vous faites la
preuve que même si le gagnant on peut le
présumer il y a des questions
extrêmement intéressantes et il y a des
points d'interrogation qui sont là et on
va répondre le peuple va répondre à ça
en partie je le disais tout à l'heure on
a décidé cette année mesdames et
messieurs d'amener un peu de Québec un
peu de Montréal et un peu des régions
sur le plateau et de pas d'avoir d'ex
nécessairement de partie mais d'exmère
on a deux ex-mer et une mairesse
actuelle Régis labom mère de Québec
expert de Québec Manon aussi mais reste
de chibougamo et Luc Ferrandez ex je
referai pas deux fois la même blague
mère du Plateau Mont-Royal bonsoir à
vous trois bonsoir merci d'être là donc
c'est intéressant vous êtes bien
enraciné vous connaissez votre milieu
tour de table rapide vous surveille quoi
on sent définitivement du BIP artiste ou
du tripartisme on a un modèle plus
européen dépendant pardonnez-moi je vais
on a des images qui viennent d'entrer de
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon qui écoute
donc la soirée électorale à Boucherville
ils sont réunis les pékistes dans un
hôtel de Boucherville Maurice et
Lorraine et le raide pardonnez-moi on
voit sa chef de cabinet également avec
lui donc c'est traditionnel tous les
chefs ne se sont pas prêtés au jeu cette
année mais il y a des prises d'images
pendant le début de la soirée après ils
disent merci bonsoir On va écouter la
soirée plus tranquillement donc voilà
Régis
avec une vraie gauche et une vraie
droite et évidemment moi c'est Québec
le Parti conservateur est né à Québec la
question est-ce qu'il est
sous-estimé dans les sondages comme de
sont souvent les parties de droite aussi
le plafonner ou quelque chose très
produit lorsque on a appris que Monsieur
James ne payait pas ses factures alors
c'est la grande question
lui se présente lui-même actuellement ne
pas le meilleur résultat dans la région
de troisième résultat à parler de bons
ce serait très intéressant je n'ai
l'impression que c'est pour monter ça va
monter dans plusieurs côtés en même
temps très bien Manon vos premières
impressions alors vous allez me
permettre de saluer les gens donnez-moi
ce soir sa première fois depuis
longtemps que j'étais à Montréal au lieu
de chez nous pour rester la soirée
nationale mais définitivement je vais
quand même surveiller ou un Orada tes
médicaments étant donné le contexte avec
la fonderie est-ce qu'il s'est passé et
on verra pour la suite et je suis
toujours un petit peu anxieuse de voir
le taux de participation je me dis qu'au
Québec on devrait voter surtout quand on
a une palette de couleur celle que de
dire assez quand même important là pour
avoir du choix pour les citoyens le vote
est un peu puis je vais vous le montrer
tout à l'heure dans quelques secondes
mais le vote est un peu plus élevé c'est
quand même une nouvelle intéressante Luc
à il y a deux choses à surveiller
premièrement est-ce que la CAC va devoir
gouverner 4 ans sans candidats forts
dans Montréal les thèmes que la carte
aborde l'immigration le développement
économique la langue etc si on n'a pas
déjà de Montréal qui sont forts pour
parler au Conseil des ministres ils vont
avoir ils vont être en déficit de
crédibilité la deuxième chose ce qui va
se passer à Montréal avec les parties
d'opposition va déterminer ce qui va se
passer dans 4 ans est-ce que les
libéraux vont être confinés à des
compter uniquement anglophones est-ce
que le Parti québécois va garder une une
position va rentrer à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que QS va pour la
première fois décroître ou va continuer
de croître très bien alors le point de
départ de tout ça je vous le montre
mesdames et messieurs la CAC à la
dissolution non pas la dernière élection
maladie solution avait 76 députés le PLQ
27qs 10 qui est le même score qu'ils
avaient eu lors de l'élection générale
ils ont pas eu de changement il y a pas
eu essentiel il y a pas eu de départ le
Parti québécois c'est plutôt que les 10
élus la dernière fois quatre
indépendants et le Parti conservateur du
Québec vous le savez il y a eu un une
transfuge qui a permis à Éric duem
d'avoir d'être représenté à l'Assemblée
nationale majorité 63 vous allez je vais
vous le montrer quand ils vont
apparaître vous allez avoir le nombre en
tout temps 63 c'est pour obtenir une
majorité monsieur le goût avait
largement une majorité la dernière fois
et on verra jusqu'où il ira toute
participation
44,6 donc
45%, c'est à 17 heures en comparaison il
était à 41% à 16 heures en 2018 donc on
peut penser on peut penser qu'il y a un
peu plus de gens qui sont allés voter à
voir c'est pas c'est pas nécessairement
comme ça l'an dernier je vous le
rappelle l'an dernier 2018 il y avait eu
66%, le taux de participation au Québec
et on jugeait que c'est vraiment trop
bas donc les gens espèrent que ça
regrimpe en haut du 70 parce qu'elle
prend Hélène parlant de vote vous êtes à
Québec devant un bureau de vote ouvert
encore pendant 19 minutes vous êtes dans
la circonscription de Jean Le Sage
Jean Le Sage actuellement détenu par
sols génétique tente de se faire réalire
pour Quebec solidaire et c'est une
circonscription
qu'on a choisi parce que ici c'est
intéressant les enjeux de transport on a
beaucoup parlé du troisième lien du
tunnel entre Québec et les vies durant
la campagne électorale or ici c'est du
très concret pour les électeurs parce
que la sortie centre-ville du côté de
Québec ben ce serait dans la
circonscription de Jean Lesage où tout à
côté là parce que c'est dans le secteur
Soumande alors donc le tunnel verrait sa
sortie là dans la circonscription où on
se trouve en même temps il y a aussi le
tramway qui passe par ici une
circonscription qui est composée du
secteur de Limoilou qui va un peu plus à
gauche prend plus le transport en commun
puis du secteur Beauport peut-être plus
au centre ou à droite les gens sont plus
dépendants de la voiture et justement le
tramway la coalition va venir Québec a
changé le trajet dans la circonscription
devait passer d'un secteur Limoilou pour
monter à Charlesbourg on l'a transféré
pour qu'il aille vers l'est alors
qu'est-ce que les électeurs vont choisir
comment vont-ils analyser situation
c'est son pour le tunnel contre le
tunnel ça risque de faire changer aussi
leur vote alors ici vraiment il y a des
impacts concrets à toute cette question
du troisième lien à toute cette caption
également des transports en commun dans
la ville de Québec et Dieu sait qu'on a
beaucoup parlé du troisième livre dans
cette campagne il y a des gens qui
pouvaient plus que fermer la télé ils
arrêtaient je recevais des courriels
d'insultes monsieur Roy vraiment vous
manquez d'imagination mais on a c'est
que les journalistes de partout ont posé
la question vous riez justement mais
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
votre troisième lien mais moi j'étais un
petit peu tanné
on revient toujours
il y avait des cachoteries à la limite
potentiellement des mensonges il y avait
quelque chose d'important en termes
d'éthique là en terme politique alors je
les comprends sauf qu'effectivement dans
le bout parlez bon alors on verra on va
continuer à en parler je le sens Mathieu
proche vous êtes à Montréal dans un
bureau de vote dans
circonscription le chef du Parti
québécois se présente
on est dans un bureau proche de celui où
Paul Saint-Pierre plamondron a voté un
peu plus tôt ce matin puis on l'a vu
après dans une vidéo en larmes avec sa
fille dans les bras faire un appel à ses
militants à son organisation pour aller
motiver les électeurs à aller exercer
leur droit de vote alors est-ce que les
électeurs ont été mobilisés ici je viens
de raccrocher avec le directeur général
des élections qui me dit que la
participation à 16h ici
44,5% donc en fait c'est un tout petit
peu en dessous de la moyenne nationale à
16h le vote qui s'établissait à
44,6%, ça ça inclut tout le vote par
anticipation qui a été comptabilisé
aussi vous savez il y a aussi le fait
que ce vote par anticipation gagne en
popularité 98 par exemple c'était 5%
2007 10% 2012 16% à peu près puis donc
en 2022 le vote par anticipation 24,4%.
donc il y a moins de personnes qui
exercent leur droit de vote le jour du
scrutin et on le voit dans les bureaux
de vote puisqu'il y a moins de file
d'attente en fait il n'y a pas de file
d'attente c'est assez fluide un peu
partout il y a une hausse effectivement
de la participation par anticipation pas
trop de problèmes on nous signale des
pannes d'électricité dans certains
bureaux de vote dans une circonscription
qui est proche de celle-ci ici ici dans
shlaga mais le vote se poursuit quand
même jusqu'à 20h avec des génératrices
donc fluides pas de problème de
personnel on craignait qu'il y ait moins
de scrutateurs ou de secrétaire pour
accueillir les électeurs mais en fait
tout le monde sait bien organisé on a
formé du personnel jusqu'à hier
exassurer que tout fonctionne
aujourd'hui et le résultat c'est que
tout fonctionne effectivement plutôt
bien merci Mathieu et le directeur
général des élections qui était sur nos
ondes plutôt RDI nous a dit bon il
s'était effectivement un débrouillé
devant l'absence de main d'oeuvre dans
certaines circonscriptions deux que le
vote par anticipation qui a quand même
été très fort historiquement fort et
compter depuis 18 heures lui nous
parlait d'une avalanche de résultats à
20h45 mais on comprend que les premiers
résultats que vous allez entendre avec
nous c'est le vote par anticipation
beaucoup donc pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que dans certains de
circonscriptions ça fait pas de
différence dans d'autres ça peut être
une grande différence les gens qui
votent participation ne votent pas
nécessairement comme les gens qui
suivent plus tard Sébastien Bovet on le
disait Alex le disait il y a vraiment
Montréal c'est fascinant Québec c'est
fascinant l'esprit c'est fascinant l'as
du Québec il y a plein de vrais luttes
là et comme c'est moi qui contrôle la
carte je vous amène d'abord dans ma
région chouchou ça va ma région chouchou
c'est
Barça Laurent Gaspésie en fait c'est
beaucoup plus l'Est du Québec en
dentelle en incluant la côte nord aussi
dans cette région là il y a combien de
circonscriptions il y en a 9 combien à
partir de particulier donc ça passe ou
ça casse dans cette région là pour le
Parti québécois qui espère conserver la
majorité de ces circonscriptions
incluant les îles de la semaines qu'on
ne voit pas sur la carte je vous mon
taux du Québec vous amène plus à l'ouest
la région de Régis la Baume la mienne
aussi je revendique que c'est aussi ma
région dans laquelle on va surveiller le
Parti conservateur en particulier où
dans Chauveau la circonscription dans
laquelle Eric dums le chef du Parti
conservateur se présente on verra donc
s'il réussi à se faire élire dans cette
circonscription là mais si on arrive Sud
aussi deux circonscriptions bosnord les
militants du parti conservateur on dit
iridien on n'a pas besoin de toi pendant
la campagne électorale il a quand même
senti le besoin d'y aller hier pour la
dernière journée de campagne et bosse
Sud où les conservateurs pensent aussi
avoir des chances de l'emporter ensuite
je vous amener dans un endroit où je
vous amène pas souvent dans les soirées
électorales l'île de Montréal vous
l'avez dit ce sera un enjeu l'île de
Montréal cette fois-ci combien de
circonscriptions sur l'île de Montréal
27 10
27 comme ça
il y en a combien qui appartiennent au
Parti libéral 19 puis d'habitude on en
parle pas parce que c'est réglé d'avance
les libéraux conservent tout l'Ouest
Québec Solidaire est au centre puis le
bleu que vous voyez d'un
traditionnellement c'est le bleu du
Parti québécois dans l'Est mais là c'est
le bleu de la coalition à venir Québec
le bleu poudre qui s'est installé aux
dernières élections la question qu'on va
se poser c'est ici au centre quelles
circonscription pourrait être chaudement
débattu on parle notamment de Maurice
Richard de Verdun ici
Henri Sainte-Anne qui est la
circonscription de Madame de Madame
Anglade la chef du Parti libéral et
finalement je vous amène dans une de vos
régions chouchous Laval combien de
circonscription à Laval 6 combien
libérale 5 en 2018 là le la coalition à
venir Québec espère que au fil au bout
de la soirée on aura inversé ce résultat
la coalition Québec aimerait bien avoir
5 des 6 circonscriptions à la fin de la
soirée très bien merci Sébastien Mathieu
proche nous parlait de panne
d'électricité mais dans Notre Dame de
Grâce il y a trois bureaux de vote qui
sont qui sont fermés en fait qui sont
interrompus en interrompu le déroulement
du vote contenu qui a pas d'électricité
alors pourtant il fait un temps
magnifique mais c'est comme ça il y a
une panne d'électricité dans Notre Dame
de Grâce ailleurs aussi nous disait-on
alors on va suivre ça pour vous
dans des écoles pardon c'est parce qu'on
fait les bureaux de vote dans les écoles
en effet le déficit de maintenance dans
les écoles et de 50%. au Québec
on va suivre ça je disais ceux qui ont
suivi cette campagne de A à Z nos
journalistes sur le terrain qui suivent
les cinq parties Véronique prince est
avec laque alexandre Duval avec le Parti
libéral Valérie Gamache avec Québec
solidaire Sébastien Desrosiers avec le
Parti québécois et Jacques Audret
Charbonneau avec le Parti conservateur
bonsoir à vous cinq je commence avec
vous Véronique vous êtes au théâtre
Capitole à Québec ou monsieur Legault et
la cas ont décidé de faire le
rassemblement ce soir
il est avec sa famille ses deux garçons
en ce moment sa conjointe Isabelle Bret
dans une chambre en train d'écouter la
soirée électorale un petit peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui c'est rendu au quartier
général de la région de Québec pour
prononcer un discours encouragé ses
bénévoles
ça va être important de rassembler après
la campagne électorale de rassembler les
gens de toutes les origines alors
référence à la question de l'immigration
des plaies à monsieur Legault il en a
parlé plus qu'il ne l'aurait voulu dans
cette campagne électorale là notamment
par sa faute parce qu'on se rappelle du
moment où il a dit que d'augmenter les
seuils d'immigration ce serait
suicidaire ça c'était pas prévu c'était
pas dans le discours c'était dans une
entrevue avec le président de la Chambre
de commerce mais à partir du moment où
l'a dit son équipe s'est dit on va
l'assumer c'est correct sauf que c'est
arrivé en même temps qu'ils ont su
qu'elles étaient les propos du ministre
Jean Boulay prononcé dans un dans un
débat une semaine plutôt où il disait
que 80% des immigrants étaient à
Montréal par les pas français Nader
repos valeur et ça ça les a vraiment
pris au dépourvu parce que si l'équipe
de Monsieur boulet les avait avertis ils
auraient pu recadrer le message avoir un
genre de plantes contingence organisé de
tourner d'entrevue mais il s'attendait
pas du tout à ça et ça a été quand même
une mauvaise journée qui a marqué leur
fin de campagne on a un extrait qu'on
peut aller écouter
une campagne électorale qu'on le veuille
ou non surtout quand il y a 5 parties
c'est divisé
tout le monde essaye de se distinguer de
s'attaquer on est vu une coupe
m'attaquer depuis 5 semaines là je m'y
attendais mais on a beau s'y attendre
mais je suis resté de bonne humeur
alors Véronique il est il est il est en
train d'écouter bien sûr la soirée puis
il attend comme nous les résultats dans
8 minutes ce qu'on aura des images de de
lui et de sa famille
oui on les aura vers 20h15 20h30 très
bien merci beaucoup Véronique à tout de
suite on s'en va voir alexandre Duval à
Montréal au Théâtre Corona avec les
libéraux Dominique englade elle a besoin
que son vote là
première moitié de campagne de Madame
anglais n'a pas été facile la deuxième
moitié a été meilleur mais il y a une
chose qui est restée content constante à
travers toute la campagne c'est que les
militants libéraux ont les chercher dans
bien des rassemblements parfois ils
étaient une dizaine des fois une
vingtaine mais jamais vraiment plus que
quelques dizaines et là ça pose toutes
sortes de questions où sont-ils ces
militants là est-ce que la marque de
commerce libéral est toujours aussi
forte qu'avant est-ce que Dominique
Anglade est parvenu à faire prendre aux
parties libérales le virage qu'elle
voulait lui faire prendre et je vous
dirais que le résultat qu'on aura ce
soir répondra peut-être en partie à ces
questions là madame Anglade espère des
gains à l'extérieur de l'île de Montréal
en même temps il faut qu'elle fasse il
faut qu'elle sécurise
photo fort et ça c'est pas gagné il y a
peut-être des luttes qui vont nous
garder éveiller très tard ce soir et la
clé pour elle c'est effectivement que
ces électeurs libéraux se rendent aux
urnes mais il y a rien de gagner si on
les voyait pas sur le terrain pourquoi y
aurait-il voter aujourd'hui la machine
libérale était vraiment en marche
aujourd'hui juste pour vous donner une
idée là il y a eu près de 100 000 appels
téléphoniques qui ont été faits dans
seulement 20 côtés pour inciter ces
électeurs-là à se rendre aux urnes
aujourd'hui malgré tout vous allez
l'entendre madame Anglade elle est très
sereine
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir tout donné
dans cette campagne d'avoir mis toutes
les idées de la vente d'avoir été
d'avoir été à l'écoute aussi et d'avoir
été moi-même d'abord et avant tout
d'avoir été moi-même puis donc c'est
pour ça que je suis je vais avec ce
sentiment du devoir du devoir accompli
aujourd'hui
très bien tout de suite oui
au Théâtre Corona un petit peu plus tard
vers 21h et on aura j'imagine aussi des
images merci beaucoup à tout de suite
Valérie gamma je vais être au Mt Luce à
Montréal également avec Québec solidaire
ouais et là les militants commencent à
arriver ici une fois assez jeune je vous
dirais on nous disait un petit peu plus
tôt d'ailleurs qu'il y avait une file
sur la rue Sainte-Catherine pour
assister à ses rassemblement militants
on attend peut-être 1500 personnes mais
Gabriel Dubois lui en quelque sorte
manqué ces dernières apparition publique
aujourd'hui parce que le seul moment où
on pouvait donc rencontrer le chef où il
aurait pu faire un appel aux électeurs
c'était au bureau de scrutin au moment
où il se rendait voter mais la directeur
de scrutin dans le coin n'a pas vraiment
voulu que les journalistes astuces à ce
moment elle a accepté que les caméras
ils soient mais les autres tenues à
l'écart et donc on a eu quelques images
de Gabriel Nadaud Dubois mais vraiment
avec cette dame là qui est interposante
les caméras et la boîte de scrutin et ça
fait en sorte qu'elle nous a pour
chasser jusqu'à à l'extérieur de ce
bureau de scrutin et qui Gabriel a 12
mois finalement n'a pas pu faire lamelle
est presque il avait prévu faire je
sentence qu'il a eu le temps de nous
dire et également les excuses que Pierre
Reed a présenté au nom du directeur
général des élections de son bureau donc
ou un peu plus tôt à l'émission je vous
laisse donc entendre Gabriel nado Dubois
et Pierre-Louis
ça c'est très bien passé
j'ai fait mon choix pour la
circonscription de Gouin
directeur général des élections
générales de responsabilité et je suis
désolé de la situation de ce matin et je
présente mes excuses au journaliste qui
était présent je pense que les règles
devront être revus réévaluer parce que
pour son équité là quant à la couverture
médiatique pour tous les candidats
en tout cas cette dame va s'en souvenir
longtemps et je disais on l'a pas nommé
on voulait pas de l'accorder elle
pensait bien faire mais disons que ça
allait contre une grande tradition
depuis depuis qu'il y a de la télévision
merci beaucoup à tout de suite Sébastien
Desrosiers vous êtes à l'Hôtel Mortagne
à Boucherville c'est là que le Parti
québécois décide de tenir son
rassemblement
oui vous l'avez vu un peu plus tôt pour
saint-pierre-la-mondon et dans un salon
avec sa famille regarde la soirée
électorale ici ça ne fait que commencer
alors il est un peu tôt pour dire
qu'elle est l'ambiance mais aujourd'hui
en tout cas l'ambiance était bonne Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon quand il s'est
rendu voté semblait heureux disait le
ciel est bleu bleu PQ on l'imagine vous
souviendrait sans doute qu'il avait
prédit au début de la campagne que le
parti québécoise serait l'équipe
Cendrillon du tournoi il estime avoir
mené une bonne campagne ça être fait
connaître notamment grâce au débat et on
a senti sur le terrain une vague de
sympathie envers lui la question c'est
de savoir est-ce que cette vague de
sympathie va se transformer en vote ce
soir ou comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
sinon le carrosse de Cendrillon pourrait
se transformer en citrouille il a dit un
peu plus tôt aujourd'hui que le taux de
participation sera important quand il
est allé encourager remercier ses
bénévoles dans son local électoral de
Camille lorrain il a d'ailleurs retrouvé
sa famille à ce moment-là qu'il n'avait
pas beaucoup vu depuis un mois il a
semblé fatigué derniers jours et vous
savez parfois les émotions prennent le
dessus à ces moments-là alors Mathieu
vous en avez parlé un peu plus tôt voici
cet extrait où le chef du PQ s'adresse à
ces militants
ça a été une campagne
très belle
c'est
une campagne dont on peut être très
fière fait aujourd'hui ce qui nous reste
c'est de d'aller vers les gens les
inciter à voter
avec la petite Lorette je crois que j'ai
dit un autre nom tout à l'heure
mais je me suis repris Laurette c'est
Laurette effectivement
audrais vous êtes au Manoir du Lac de
l'âge à Québec dans le côté de Chauveau
et c'est un vrai test pour Éric duenne
absolument c'est l'objectif numéro 1
qu'il
se fait facile dans Chauveau la lutte va
être chaude avec le député caquiste
sortant Sylvain Lévesque on nous dit du
côté de Monsieur Duhem qui les confiant
et qu'il veut causer des surprises parce
que le vote conservateur est un peu
difficile à estimer selon lui parce
qu'on n'a pas de comparatif
rappelez-vous en 2018 le Parti
conservateur a récolté 1,46% des voix 60
000 votes environ il compte autant de
membres aujourd'hui donc pour Éric Duhem
le mot d'ordre c'est que c'est une
victoire peu importe qui va se passer
évidemment on veut faire élire des
députés on a les yeux rivés sur beau Sud
bosnord dans les rêves les plus fous des
conservateurs on pourrait débordés vers
Bellechasse arrivé deuxième aussi dans
des circonscriptions dans chaudière à
palaches ou encore à Québec ce serait
une victoire pour iridium ça préparait
la prochaine élection en 2026
aujourd'hui le dit qu'il était en fait
satisfait du fait que le taux de
participation pour le vote par
anticipation était ça pourrait lui
servir écoutons et régulièrement
notre profil d'électeurs est un profil
qui normalement traditionnellement votre
moins et mais cette fois-ci les motiver
donc est-ce que ça peut changer quelque
chose moi je pense que c'est pas le fait
que par exemple le bureau de vote par
anticipation ont connu plus de succès
cette année je pense que c'est pas
étranger à notre montée le fait que
c'est dans la région de Québec une chose
qui est sûr c'est sûr que tu en as
peut-être pas le même stress que les
autres parties parce qu'on est la seule
formation politique aujourd'hui qui est
certaine de faire mieux que la dernière
fois ça je pense que personne qui peut
contester ça de notre part
très bien j'encoudrer merci il l'a
répété à plusieurs reprises depuis
quelques jours il dit peu importe le
résultat il prépare son monde aussi ses
militants ce qui a peut-être zéro un
député monsieur Djem en direct imaginé
on est parti de un point 6 %, on est à
10 11 12 on verra 13 où ça va se
terminer alors voilà madame et Messieurs
les vrais affaires commencent dans
exactement 5 secondes on va fermer les
bureaux de scrutin
[Musique]
alors ça y est il est 20h les jeux sont
faits les votes sont dans les boîtes et
on va recevoir très rapidement les
premiers résultats Sébastien la carte
maintenant elle est toute grise voilà la
carte est toute grise et c'est au
Québécois de la destinée en fait les
Québécois ont dessiné la carte s'agit de
voir quelle couleur sera appliquée au
cours des prochaines heures et au fil
donc du dépouillement des votes cette
carte prendra des couleurs nous allons
tout au long de la soirée affichée vous
allez le voir arriver les logos des
partis avec le nombre de députés de
candidats pardonnez-moi élu ou en tête
qu'avec
US pqpcq je le disais ça vaut la peine
qu'on le ressouling aux gens qui nous
écoutent c'est très rare et on a eu un
débat à 5 on le souligné que cinq
parties sont en mesure de faire élire
des députés avec cinq parties qui sont
compétitifs donc cinq parties il y en a
déjà eu mes cinq parties qui peuvent
prétendre aspirer à avoir un siège à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est très rare
même au fédéral c'est pas le cas parce
que en général c'est une bataille à
trois ou à 4 dépendamment des régions 5
c'est quand même très inhabituel est-ce
que cette dynamique là peut durer parce
que ça crée aussi un fragmentation du
vote de position qui pourrait favoriser
la caque on verra bien ce soir mais
c'est clair que ça fait une dynamique
très particulière ce soir dans les
résultats et ils ont aussi hâte que nous
les 810 candidats d'avoir les premiers
résultats oui il y a eu des sondages qui
montrait à peu près Chantal la même
chose n'empêche dans plusieurs régions
les sondages dans une circonscription ah
mais voilà on a déjà des résultats
extraordinaires la rapidité ce soir
premiers résultats dans Market ou
Enrique le libéral le tir de l'arrière
mais vous voyez un bureau sur 157 market
les libéraux ne veulent pas laisser
échapper cette circonscription là on va
suivre ça dans le l'ouest de Montréal
aux yeux de la Madeleine Joël Arsenault
qui est en avance pour l'instant sur
Jonathan Lapierre le maire ça c'est un
combat de coq aux îles entre les deux ça
a été assez agressif comme campagne
électorale on verra six Joël Arsenault
maintient l'avance deux montagnes des
premiers résultats grosse grosse avance
ça c'est pas une surprise pour Benoît
Charette ministre l'environnement
698 il y a simplement 6 bureaux sur 165
alors ça dites-vous que c'est dans
Jonquières c'est Yannick Gagnon qui est
en avance sur Caroline Dubé la péquiste
et troisième Isabelle champagne du Parti
conservateur
très forte avance encore une fois c'est
le vote par anticipation n'empêche une
Gava madame cire Denis Lamotte le caquis
qui le député sortant qui est un très
mince avance deux bureaux on va suivre
ça parce que ça ça peut être serré
madame
qu'on voit des résultats d'un Rosemont
une avance pour la kakis sur Vincent
Marisol mais un bureau sur 186 donc
monsieur Marissal pour l'instant
la soirée jeune comme on dit je disais
un Gava Lucio peut-être ce soir
peut-être mais ça va dépendre toute
participation finale et malheureusement
ou heureusement dépendamment du point de
vue c'est pas une lutte à deux c'est une
lutte avec une opposition fragmentée
comme vous dites ici mais on verra alors
à un bureau de de une boîte là c'est
on a rien à dire pour l'instant encore
faut-il savoir où est-ce qu'elle est la
boîte
dans ce genre de circonscription là où
il y a des clivages géographiques
régionaux qui sont internes donc et
c'est le vote par anticipation les 15 20
premières minutes que vous allez voir
c'est le vote par anticipation ça vous
donne une idée de l'état de santé des
machines électorales ceux qui ont réussi
à faire voter leurs votes visiblement
c'est de la coalition à venir à Québec
qui d'après les sondages avait un vote
un peu plus âgé les 55 ans plus qui
votent beaucoup par anticipation c'est
ce qu'on voit au fil de la soirée on va
voir les votes d'aujourd'hui entrée
public peut-être un peu plus jeune
électeur un peu plus jeune ça pourrait
faire basculer certaines
circonscriptions on va aller voir
Sébastien le PLQ on a une
circonscription en avance le PQ une QS
une ils sont à égalité chacun en ont une
pour l'instant ce début de résultat bon
mais sans surprise dans l'Ouest l'île de
Montréal ici quoi que dans cette
circonscription ici de market c'est
peut-être la surprise pour l'instant
avec cinq voix d'avance pour la
coalition de Québec soit super jeune
comme vous le dites heureusement ici ça
s'est promené au début entre partie de
Québec entre coalition Québec et Québec
solidaire mais c'est une circonscription
solidaire donc défendue par Vincent donc
ça commence à prendre non mais
tranquillement de la couleur alors bosse
Nord 1er résultat qu'on nous qu'on nous
donne je vous souligne que c'est un gros
départ oui c'est préliminaire mais gros
départ pour la CAQ partout en
pourcentage lutte provençal qui est en
avance sur le candidat Olivier Dumet
dont on parlait de des conservateurs
dans show Médée
monsieur Planet qui est en avant sur la
libérale ça c'était on disait si on
gardait dans Laval et libéraux ce sera
cheminée attendons voir n'empêche un
empêche ça sort et pour l'instant ça
sort très très fort pour la CAQ dans
saint François
Geneviève Hébert qui est en avance la
caquiste donc Saint-François qui
resterait kakis Mélissa généreux qui est
troisième mais un bureau donc on est
dans les 23 28 votes vous l'aurez
compris mais on vous les donne les îles
la Madeleine Jonathan Lapierre qui est
en avance sur joie l'arsenault donc là
je sens qu'on va en parler plusieurs
fois ils vont se croire
à la fin là
c'est un sur le goût Garcia là 48% ce
qui est sorti il aime ce qu'il voit
être à sa place
ça donne une idée de tendance c'est vrai
que le vote par anticipation souvent ce
sont les électeurs plus âgés que c'est
une tranche d'électeurs qui a tendance à
être plus favorable à la coalition
Québec que d'autres tranches néanmoins
on aime toujours mieux fini commencer
comme ça
j'ai vu des soirées ou des gens qui
commençaient comme ça ont perdu mais je
pense pas que ce soit nécessairement que
ce soit ouais en tout cas
il a partout on n'a pas de résultats en
outtawaï en Mauricie sinon on a des
résultats partout dans les régions et le
pourcentage de la CAQ et très fort et
l'aval regardez Sébastien là-bas elle
est en train de se peinturer un peu en
bleu poudre de la coalition Québec femme
ici Sainte-Rose c'était déjà une
circonscription qui leur appartenait
show Médée remarqué qu'avec 17% des
votes si je vois bien le tableau en ce
moment le Parti québécois n'est en
avance dans aucune circonscription
malgré le 17% des votes c'est quand même
ça pourrait être un problème pour le
Parti québécois pour faire élire des
députés ce choix il y a un parti
conservateur le voici celui le chiffre 1
vous voyez conservateur Christian
Gauthier dans l'autre binaire Frontenac
qui est en avance sur Isabelle Lecourt
qui est la député sortante donc avoir
déjà quand je vous dis que ça va aller
vite mesdames et messieurs dans Rousseau
réélu Louis Charles Thuin qui est élu
pour la deuxième fois donc je vous
rappelle que monsieur Legault a déjà été
il est dans l'Assomption mais déjà été
député d'un ruisseau dans sa première
vue dans une autre incarnation police
quand Bernard Landry était allé le
chercher pour faire de la politique
les deux
regardez la carte Sébastien je dis un
palace je tiens votre attention sur le
binaire Frontenac ici ou le Parti
conservateur est en avance par 40
petites voix seulement trois boîtes
évidemment de scrutin de dépouiller on
surveillait surtout beau ce Nord beau
Sud mais pour l'instant Boston ça tient
pour le colissium avenir Québec et
d'abord Sud aussi le pcq est deuxième on
va voir que c'est la lutte des poulets
juste pour voir dans beau Sud ils sont
les trois en première position mais
c'est Samuel de la coalition Québec qui
est en avance pour l'instant donc ce
sera une région qu'on surveiller
beaucoup ce soir la région de labo
habituellement dans chaudière à palache
le Parti conservateur récolte 39% des
intentions de vote laquelle le Québec
intentions
elle récolte officiellement 38% des
votes ce soir la coalition de Québec est
à 45 c'est quand même donc très serré là
ça veut dire que plusieurs
circonscriptions de cette région là
arrive sud de Québec vont être
surveiller toute la soirée alors
d'autres résultats aux jeux de la
Madeleine on disait ça va se recroiser
Joël Arsenault qui est en avance sur
Jonathan Lapierre maintenant de
186 voix il y a 18 bureaux quand même ça
commence à significatif sur 53 à suivre
donc aux îles mais Joël Arsenault qui
pourrait et ça ailleurs c'est le seul et
qu'est-ce qui est en avance pour
l'instant c'est aux îles et on n'a pas
de résultats je crois dans matters de
matapedia pour l'instant avoir n'a pas
encore
Saint-François Geneviève Hébert qui
garde sa position de tête qui est la
député sortante dans saint François
ça c'était un espoir de Québec solitaire
qui est loin pour l'instant dans market
5 petites voix on a que deux bureaux de
dépouiller Enrico chiconique qui traîne
l'arrière ça on va le surveiller parce
que c'est Ville Lasalle l'Ouest les
libéraux dit à la fin on a on croit
avoir gardé ce comté Sainte Marie
Saint-Jacques Manon Masset qui est avec
un bureau en avance c'est très
préliminaire
alors vous le voyez c'est un gros gros
gros coup gros départ pour la CAQ ça
rentre rapidement déjà 25
circonscriptions ils sont en avance ou
sur le point de les prendre donc c'est
un départ canon pour la coalition à
Québec
[Musique]
Radio-Canada prévoit que le prochain
gouvernement sera dirigé par la
Coalition avenir Québec François Legault
qui sera majoritaire
20h10 Radio-Canada prévoit un
gouvernement de la CAQ majoritaire
monsieur Legault qui a donc on voit des
images du rassemblement à Québec gagné
son pari les beaucoup de gens qu'on
verra comment tout ça va se traduire
dans toutes les régions du Québec ont un
peu dit vous avez pas eu un vrai mandat
continuez pour reprendre son slogan
parce que il y a eu la pandémie qui vous
a enlevé deux ans il a redessiné la
carte politique du Québec il va
continuer à le faire avec son
nationalisme sans rupture Véronique vous
êtes au rassemblement c'est
évidemment la joie même qu'on s'y attend
c'est une joie et on doit être très
content des chiffres des pourcentages
moi je ne vous entends pas
allez-y
là je vous entends un peu mieux allez je
vais
vous montrer
ça commence à se rappeler alors ce sont
principalement des employés pour
l'instant de la coalition à venir Québec
on sait que la CAQ a tout près de 400
employés et on leur a demandé de venir
ici de venir encourager de venir avec
les bénévoles et les candidats
commencent à arriver tranquillement pas
vite j'ai vu Geneviève Villebourg
Jonathan Julien et on voit qu'ils sont
de bonne humeur avec les résultats
préliminaires c'est sûr qu'ils ont
encore quelques inquiétudes là pour des
compter ou le vote conservateur peut
peut-être venir brouiller les cartes
mais quand même jusqu'à maintenant là
vous voyez que c'est la bonne humeur qui
règne ici ben oui on les comprend avec
les chiffres qu'ils ont devant les yeux
il est à écouter ce n'est pas des
blagues et à 52% actuellement mais il y
a des régions je le répète ça va se
pourcentage là risque de fléchir
n'empêche c'est énorme énorme comme
départ tour de table sur ce sur cette
formation du gouvernement
Luc je commence avec vous tour de table
première impression c'est trop
préliminal dans les dans les compter où
c'est très serré et c'est trop
préliminant pour se prononcer là j'ai
regardé Verdun et Morice Richard même
Vincent morissal qui est à la peine ça
me semble surprenant alors pour
l'instant je préfère me m'abstenir de
parler sur la victoire de Monsieur et
bien indéniable mais je le disais tantôt
s'il avait été élu avec 38 % des votes
ça aurait été le gouvernement
majoritaire qui a été élu avec le plus
petit pourcentage de vote mais ça semble
être plus que ça donc il va échapper à
ce soir alors avec une division
d'opposition la seule raison qui aurait
fait qui aurait été élu à 38% c'est la
division d'opposition mais il semble
vouloir échapper à ce soir
a gagné son pari l'équipe ce soir vous
continuez je suis en fin de mauvais jeu
de mots parce qu'il y a quand même été
deux ans et demi en pandémie puis disent
bien continuer à
un peu de position moi je suis à peu
près
que ce soit très fragmentaire c'est très
fort pour laquelle très fort c'est très
fort et Sébastien juste un tour de
cartes et ensuite avec les Chantal je
vais vous donner la parole mais voyons
voir à quoi ça ressemble passons région
de Montréal à Londres la région de
Québec il y en a deux il y en a le Parti
québécois viennent perdre Jonquières en
passant c'est Yannick Gagnon c'est un
gain de Québec solidaire donc le Parti
québécois est rayé de la carte
oui qu'est-ce que j'ai dit de la CAQ et
dans les gens québécon surveillait les
circonscriptions de Chauveau
actuellement la coalition Québec est en
avance de 212 voies et rids se présente
le chef du Parti conservateur dans cette
circonscription on surveillait aussi sur
la rive-sud de Québec la chaudière à
palache beau snowbo-sud pour l'instant
ça tient pour la CAQ on est sûrement une
grosse avance mais ça tient plus grosse
avance ici dans beau Sud pour la Québec
c'est un espoir pour l'instant au moment
où on se parle pour le Parti
conservateur c'est dans le binaire
Frontenac sans surprise monsieur Legault
dans l'Assomption qui est réélu dans sa
circonscription avec une écrasante
majorité évidemment monsieur Legault qui
arrive arrivera à l'Assemblée nationale
avec un grand contingent comment ça va
finir on sait pas mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que ça a commencé comme il le
souhaitait la cape du son du
rassemblement de la CAQ applaudissent la
victoire de leur chef
tournée de cartes oui côte nord une
petite surprise au moment où on se parle
dans Du Plessis mais un une voix
d'avance la coalition à venir Québec ici
à des espoirs de faire ce game et
craignait un effet Rambo un effet mesure
sanitaire c'est la région de sept-île
notamment ici tiens c'est intéressant
d'en donner l'évêque deux points
d'avance deux votes d'avance seulement
pour les candidate du Parti conservateur
donc ils sont compétitifs c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre dans ces
circonscriptions et va aller voir vous
voulez qu'on aille voir la bouche
monsieur Labeau c'est étonnant c'était
étonnant ok alors allons-y ah ben oui le
binaire frontière ça vient de retourner
en faveur de la coalition de Québec avec
87 voix bosnord pour surveillait 38
d'avance et près de 700 voix pour dans
beau Sud mais le PQ est 2e dans toutes
ces circonscriptions très bien faut se
rappeler Patrice que François Legault a
un vent en face pendant une bonne partie
de la campagne électorale mais il
partait avec un très fort vent de dos
59% des Québécois étaient Sat du
gouvernement un taux rarement vu pour un
gouvernement sortant il y a eu la
pandémie les gens se sont dit il y a pas
pu probablement aller au bout de ce
qu'il voulait il y a bien gérer ça dans
un seul grand taux de satisfaction oui
il y a eu des mécontents mais en général
les gens étaient plutôt satisfaits alors
il y a pas eu malgré tous les dérapages
de la campagne il y a pas eu
d'événements se couche susceptibles de
secouer le 59% toute satisfaction c'est
ce qui fait qu'on a un gouvernement
majoritaire à laquelle ils sont à Québec
ce soir
mais le début de soirée le plus
difficile selon moi c'est Québec
solidaire l'objectif de position
officielle ça s'en va pas là pourcentage
de votre jusqu'à présent le PQ
est plus élevé dans le pourcentage de
votes ces deux objectifs ou et on peut
se demander en regardant de la
circonscription de Rosemonde par exemple
si l'espèce de succès d'estime du PQ va
pas finir par coûter des plumes à Québec
solidaire des gens qui sont tournés à la
maison dans des circonscriptions
QS et qui
comme on le fait le bonheur de la carte
des fois Marie-Victorin il y a eu un
match récemment avec une partiel madame
dorismond qui est l'avait remporté pour
laque elle est en confortable avant
quand même d'aller voir le tableau même
si on parle que de
266 voies de plus alors on va justement
on a on a une entrevue avec
Geneviève Guilbaud très bien allons-y
Véronique vous êtes avec Geneviève
Guilbaud
alors votre première réaction c'est des
résultats préliminaires mais vous
prédisez combien de visiter par exemple
à la coalition je réponds à mesure de
donner un nom nous on a dit on aimerait
bien conserver les 76 qu'on avait déjà
pu faire des gains entre autres des
gains ici dans notre capitale nationale
là on vient de voir que notre député
sorta de Chauveau est en avance et sans
probablement gagner chevaux ce soir ça
c'est un souci qu'on avait parce qu'il y
a Monsieur James présentait là et là on
va garder chauffe-eau fort probablement
j'aimerais bien qu'on gagne Jean Le Sage
aussi il y a un certain nombre
d'endroits comme ça au Québec Sherbrooke
Maurice Richard à Montréal on a des
espoirs aussi une excellente candidate
Audrey donc c'est très très excitant ce
qui est pas en train de se passer en ce
moment puis je veux vraiment remercier
les Québécois puis remercier mes 124
collègues qui ont été députés un peu
partout au Québec pendant cette campagne
là qui est difficile toujours pour tout
le monde une campagne ce soir c'est le
verdict final et donc on est heureux
merci bonne soirée
très bien oui ben évidemment que la vis
première ministre est contente on a on
verra on n'a pas eu les résultats dans
les vies je crois dans chute de la
chaudière non plus on va et on a
d'autres résultats dans saint François
Mélissa généreux et qu'es quand Chantal
disait que c'est une soirée qui commence
difficilement on verra comment ça se
termine pendant qu'on nous amène des
résultats dans les vies Bernard
drinville qui était en forte forte
avance
c'est pas nécessairement étonnant mais
vous voyez les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes 17 sur 185 c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal terminé dans son cas
Charlevoix côte de Beaupré Karine
Bourassa qui est qui est en qui est en
tête sur Myriam Fortin que est-ce qui
est en deuxième place là dessus
Saint-François donc Mélissa généreux
QS je le disais avait beaucoup d'espoir
pour le docteur géneux elle est en
deuxième elle traîne l'arrière 6 bureaux
sur 205 quand même une avance
significative pour Geneviève Hébert qui
veut un deuxième mandat dans Du Plessis
une seule voix ça ça il y a moins de
votes alors ça peut être très serré très
longtemps mais c'est le Québec solidaire
madame Mestro cochon qui est en avance
d'une seule petite voix
mais vous avez quatre bureaux sur 158 on
a peu de bureau mais Jonquières 18
bureaux sur 160 Yannick gagne non ça
c'est un gain il a été déclaré gagnant
il a circonscription de Sylvain
Gaudreault que le PQ Perse c'est des
morceaux qui partent d'histoire pour le
PQ je mets au Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean on
n'avait pas eu de députés pékistes
depuis 1973 donc à moins d'une véritable
surprise dans une autre circonscription
jean-claire étant le meilleur espoir
quand même du PQ ça veut dire que pour
la première fois depuis 50 ans il y aura
pas de députés pékistan
ça c'est un Jonquière donc on est très
content du côté de la coalition du
Québec on est on s'est emparé de tout ce
de tout ce territoire là regardez le
Parti québécois la seule circonscription
est-ce qu'on a déjà des des résultats
dans Matane m'a tapédia alors voir si on
a des résultats dans Madame je pense
qu'on en a pas beaucoup de
circonscriptions aussi pour de Québec
solidaire pour lesquels on n'a pas
beaucoup de résultats pour l'instant ce
qui explique pourquoi
QS est à 3 circonscriptions en avance
pour l'instant
très bien alors Bernard drinville je
disais c'était une formalité monsieur
Draveil qui fait son qui refait son
entrée à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
vies on essaiera de lui parler un peu
plus tard tout à l'heure alors est-ce
que il deviendra monsieur 3e lien c'est
à voir lui on a beaucoup parlé de lui
aussi dans la fin de cette campagne
électorale pas pour les bonnes raisons
j'en voulais qui est réélu dans Trois
Rivières monsieur boulet donc
qui s'est disqualifié avait dit à votre
émission avec sera plus ministre
élu pour les libéraux les libéraux qui
en ont 13 élus en avance pour l'instant
on est très en fait tous sont très très
loin de leur score le PQ il y en a deux
peut-être c'est des premiers résultats
on verra que c'est le DR4 d'un Rosemont
on nous dit que Québec Solidaire a
repris l'avance dans Chauveau Sylvain
l'évêque qui est en avance sur Eric
Duhem monsieur Duhem qui est deuxième
mais qui est néanmoins deuxième a offert
une tournée des chefs si vous le voulez
bien on le disait il y avait trois des
cinq chefs qui étaient dont le l'avenir
est incertain monsieur Gabriel ado
Dubois un seul bureau mais qui est en
avance dans le coin lui c'est ça devrait
bien aller ce soir dans Gouin pour
Gabriel ado Dubois
très bien alors allons voir la région de
Montréal analysons donc commençons par
la balle qui est en train de se
peinturer Bleu Poudre regardez ce que ça
donnait en 2018 c'était pas mal plus
rouge Laval donc dans la circonscription
ici de femmes c'est construction de 1000
aussi le parti de la coalition Québec
expert peut-être faire un gage je veux
juste vous montrer ce qui se passe à
Montréal il y a une bataille dans les
coins
Maurice Richard ici ça c'est important
Boisy contre Audrey Murray de la
Coalition avenir Québec donc c'est une
bataille qu'on va suivre ça ce soir
parce que c'est un gain pour eux
important au détriment des libéraux
exactement les libéraux avaient fait
lire Marie Montpellier qui ne s'est pas
représenté pour à ces élections aussi et
c'est peut-être l'heure candidat sur
lequel misait le plus
président de la Banque de développement
du Canada dans market je vois votre dans
le coin rouge je vois qu'il a repris
l'avance tu connais repris l’avance dans
à côté Marguerite Bourgeois les libéraux
tiennent le coup aussi et on n'a pas
encore de résultats ici ça Henri
Sainte-Anne ou la Verdun de
circonscription qu'on surveille
particulièrement aussi ce soir
on la comprend alors oui il y a des
coins aussi beaucoup plus lents que
d'autres mais voyez le pourcentage
51% c'est énorme compte tenu de que dans
la partie il y a cinq parties politiques
pour l'instant c'était énorme alors on
attendait des votes dans l'outawa le
pourcentage va fluctuer mais c'est un
départ extrêmement fort pour laque
d'embauche nord par exemple ou la
cafetière le coût avec Luc provençal qui
brillent un troisième mandat pour la
taxe Olivier Dumet qui est pas loin
c'est ils sont deuxième il y a 13
circonscriptions au Québec où le pcq est
deuxième en ce moment bon
Saint Louis les libéraux avec Jennifer
macaron est en avance même si très
fragmentaire on serait très surpris du
contraire dans Louis Hébert genevièvebo
à qui on a parlé il y a quelques minutes
et en avance à Québec également
notre binaire Frontenac des
circonscriptions vous le voyez où le
parti conservateur est deuxième là
Isabelle Lecourt qui brille un deuxième
mandat madame Lecourt dans l'autre
binaire Frontenac donc ils ont repris la
tête mais les deuxièmes c'est le parti
conservateur parier que Monsieur Jam ce
soir va beaucoup parler de ce statut de
deuxième dans plein d'endroit
circonscription en ce moment ce sera
intéressant dans l'île de Morin de
Montréal aussi dans les communautés les
circonscriptions un peu plus anglophones
vous demandiez des résultats Patrice
pour l'Est du Québec on en a un stock un
premier résultat pour Matane matapedia
il y aura pas d'histoire ici Pascal
berbé va être élu sans histoire et
regardez ce qui se passe ici bonne
aventure par exemple c'est préliminaires
évidemment mais
le Parti québécois a un candidat vedette
Alexis Deschênes pour l'instant en léger
recul sur la candidate de la coalition
Québec
Gaspé qui est aussi une circonscription
du Parti québécois ici ça a l'air un peu
moins serré en tout cas au départ avec
Stéphane Sainte-Croix qui mène sur la
députée sortante Mégane Mélenchon et si
j'arrive à vous trouver les îles oui les
îles c'est le deuxième pour le PQ voilà
c'est la deuxième circonscription en
effet ou le PQ est en avance Joël
Arsenault mais ça ça peut encore bouger
ne sont pas fidèles les changent parfois
de députés pendant que les gens peuvent
voir le chiffre de 63 on a déjà depuis
un certain temps parler d'un
gouvernement majoritaire ben vous voyez
ils sont déjà à 63 puis il est quoi et
quelle heure est-il 20h26 c'est très
très rapide comme début de soirée
électorale on a vu d'autres et rapides
oui c'est rapide le bon le pourcentage
va bouger un peu à force que les votes
d'aujourd'hui rentrent votre
parenticipation visiblement été très
fort envers laka qu'on s'y attendait
mais ça reste un départ rapide à 51%,
les sondages étaient plutôt autour de 38
42 dépendamment la fourchette ça va
baisser un peu mais pour l'instant je
pense que du côté de François Legault on
doit être particulièrement heureux La
Pinière les libéraux garderaient j'ai vu
sur la Rive-Sud
à côté on n'est pas encore de résultats
pour la première c'est ça ah oui c'est
juste c'est mon doigt qui est trop gros
la porte La Pinière la prairie ça
devient mélangeant mais il y aura pas de
résultats dans l'opinion pour l'instant
très bien il y a des gens qui vont faire
leur entrée à l'Assemblée nationale des
nouveaux venus dans Bertrand elle est en
bonne posture France Hélène duranchot
elle n'est pas élue mais elle est
largement en avance ça c'est les
Laurentides Bertrand France Hélène
Duranceau que beaucoup de gens en tout
cas des gens de la CAQ et peut-être en
premier lieu monsieur Lego voyait voit
déjà comme ministre dans bonne aventure
Catherine Blouin qui est en avance sur
Alexis Deschênes elle serait une
nouvelle venue elle aussi ça serait un
gain dans ce cas là sur le Parti
québécois je suis de la chaudière
martine Biron qui est en avance ça avait
été une des plus grosses majorités en
2018 pour la carte c'est un des premiers
compter à des kystes à l'époque qui est
devenu kakistan suite c'est un terreau
très très fertile pour la coalition
Québec évidemment aussi pour le Parti
conservateur du Québec mais surtout pour
la CAQ ça ça va être un bon si jamais ça
se confirme pour Québec solidaire
monsieur Boisy a une boisée qui est
en avance dans Maurice Richard alors à
suivre et justement Valérie Gamache est
avec quelqu'un dans Montréal Outremont
Michel 7 lakoué qui est en avance
évidemment un set lakoué quand je disais
des nouveaux venus à l'Assemblée
nationale elle elle en fera partie
Valérie vous êtes avec Amir Cadière qui
doit pas être très heureux du début de
soirée
qui a été député de merci pour Québec
solidaire de 2008 à 2018 comment vous
vous analysez ces premiers résultats de
la soirée pour Québec solidaire c'est
sûr que pour moi c'est toujours exaltant
le seul fait qu'on parle de nos de notre
partie sur la scène québécoise nous
avons tant
espéré ce jour-là c'est à dire un parti
qui arrive peu à peu c'est peut-être pas
tout à fait fait à maturité qui a la
confiance de plus en plus de gens
maintenant moi je suis assez confiant
pour la soirée je suis sûr qu'on va
faire des gains et quel je ne peux pas
dire avec assurance mais c'est sûr que
quel que soit le résultat à la fin de la
soirée Québec solidaire s'impose quand
même comme
la voix de l'opposition principale si
c'est pas l'opposition officielle c'est
quand même la position la plus combative
à ce moment c'est j'espère que non mais
bon faut quand même entrevoir toutes les
possibilités il y a les lourdeurs
historiques de ce que c'est le Québec et
disons le fait que nous avons encore du
chemin à faire pour conquérir le pouvoir
entre ce moment et le jour au Québec
solidaire prétend 2026 assurant le
pouvoir il y a un chemin à faire est-ce
que on sera les positions officielle je
l'espère mais l'opposition véritable
celle qui est capable de mener le combat
avec monsieur Legault je pense tout le
monde a reconnu bel et bien que avec
celui-là a
on pour vous c'est possible on a vu
qu'il est en avance là oui absolument
Maurice Richard j'ai de très forte
espoir c'est le cas aussi de Verdun
j'espère qu'on aura des surprises dans
bio dans sa rue Saint temps dans
Saint-François alors j'ai hâte comme
vous de voir les résultats merci
beaucoup monsieur alors voilà Patrice
merci merci beaucoup oui mais monsieur
cadire on le voyait quand même dans le
ton respirer un départ autre pour Québec
solidaire un petit peu plus canon
certainement
des raisons s'inquiéter d'autres parts
ça prend de lancer pour se rendre à
l'opposition officielle le
fond de
commerce du Parti libéral sur l'île de
Montréal ça lui donnait une longueur
d'avance pas de la rattraper ça prend
probablement un peu plus d'élan que ce
qu'on voit depuis le début du décompte
on verra Sherbrooke amenez-nous à
Sherbrooke Sébastien c'est intéressant
parce que c'est une lutte entre une
veulette LACAQUE qui voulait ravir là
c'est chaud là et dans cette océan de
bleu poudre Sherbrooke ici c'est
toujours le Québec solidaire qui est en
avance avec la députée sortante
Christine Labrie
très légère avance avec 10 boîtes de
scrutin dépouillées sur Caroline
Saint-Hilaire une candidate vedette on
surveillait roineranda
ou aussi Québec solidaire souhaite
conserver cette circonscription mais
regardez pour l'instant c'est la
coalition à Québec est en avance avec 65
boîtes de plus deux boîtes de scrutin
dépouillés sur 166 mais n'empêche
n'empêche madame cire surveiller
beaucoup ses circonscriptions dans une
GABA pour l'instant c'est la coalition à
venir Québec qui est en avance avec 87
voix et regardez cette image arrêt sur
image quand ça parle beaucoup là
c'était comme ça avant là on voit un peu
plus de bleu de bleu poudre 10% pour
Québec solidaire c'est vraiment pas fort
jusqu'à maintenant 10% des votes
exprimés on doit pas être content chez
eux égalité avec le Parti conservateur
du Québec pour l'instant n'est pas en
avance aucune circonscription le Parti
québécois c'est les îles et m'attendent
donc c'est vraiment les deux les
îles c'est très serré donc le scénario
d'un seul est encore possible
malheureusement pour les piquets c'est
Québec solidaire à 7 ils sont loin du
compte les libéraux aussi là ils
divisent par deux et plus ce qu'ils
avaient avant donc oui ils sont
l'opposition officielle mais pour
l'instant manque beaucoup beaucoup de
votes sur l'île de Montréal
est vraiment le plus lent alors ça va
bouger pour les libéraux ça va bouger
pour Québec solidaire encore c'est
vraiment l'île de Montréal hier au
Québec ça sort assez rapidement l'île de
Montréal pour l'instant est en retard
dans le décompte très bien Sonia le elle
a parlé il y a quelques secondes on
s'envolait
merci à tous les citoyens de la
confiance
[Applaudissements]
merci des citoyens de la confiance alors
voilà une soirée qui ressemble à celle
de Dark Ford qui je crois viens
d'envoyer quelques mots à monsieur
Legault traduction libre je suis très
excité que mon ami le Premier ministre
François Legault reçoit un autre mandat
fort des électeurs du Québec on va
continuer à construire des liens
profonds avec les deux provinces et
renforcer les liens économiques qu'il y
a pour créer des bonnes Jobs payantes ça
ça va faire plaisir monsieur Lego et
surtout félicitations mon ami
félicitations
ce qui prend des cours actifs de
français monsieur
chouchou Laval on va aller faire un
petit truc des résultats
d'un Fabre la cakes qui est en voie de
remporter ces préliminaires n'empêche
c'est une bonne avance Alice Abou Khalil
Laval des rapides madame Ethan qui est
en avance sur Sao Paulo qui était le
seul qui se représentait pour les
libéraux à Laval tous les autres avaient
quitté ça conscription au baromètre des
rapides très rare qu'il va du mauvais
côté mille Julie Saïd qui est en avance
également sur la candidate libérale
Francine Charbonneau qui se représentait
pas pour les libéraux et dans cheminée
comme prévu comme prévu la candidate
libérale tient le fort pour l'instant
donc il en reste une Sébastien voilà et
c'est ici avec le contraste avec 2018 et
frappant quand on regarde à quel point
le Parti libéral était présent donc on
voit des images de monsieur Legault qui
est avec Madame braise on épouse qui
écoute la soirée
et avec ces deux garçons Xavier et
Victor sur le groupe qui est tout
sourire on ne serait à moins
qui il faut le dire on l'a pas mal dit
pendant tout au long de la campagne qui
a trouvé des bouts difficiles de cette
campagne électorale qui semblait dire
pourquoi on s'acharne imposer certaines
questions sur le troisième lien sur
l'immigration sur différents dossiers
mais il a
ce qu'il voulait ce soir
totalement on va probablement pas
embrasser sa sœur ce soir le premier va
faire attention
la dernière fois il y avait eu tellement
d'enthousiasme qui s'était précipité
mais là je pense qu'on va faire
attention deuxième fois on fera pas
l'erreur
très bien alors oui il part avec on
verra jusqu'où ça va aller si ça si ça
se maintenait là on a des résultats dans
105 circonscriptions sur 125 donc ça va
encore bouger les chiffres que vous
voyez mais
de toute façon allons à Québec solidaire
[Applaudissements]
matapedia donc le Parti québécois qui
prenait ça on a trois élus en avance le
seul élu c'est monsieur Bérubé c'était
écrit dans le ciel monsieur Bérubé
allait s'il n'en restait qu'un seul être
lui debout fort et effectivement très
fort dans sa circonscription Sébastien
et à Québec il y a une petite histoire
qui s'écrit peut-être tâchereau ici
c'est le parti de Québec solidaire qui
est en avance assez confortable avec 300
voix d'avance mais juste à côté genre
c'est la circonscription du député seul
Zanetti le député sortant pour l'instant
il tient de l'arrière mais il y a 7
boîtes de scrutin d'appuyées sur
161 Juifs je vous ai amener sur l'île de
Montréal parce que il y a deux
circonscriptions du coup dernière
nouvelle quand j'avais vérifié qui nous
intéresse peut-être particulièrement
Anjou Louis riez c'est conscription
libérale pour l'instant c'est la
coalition Québec qui est en avance et
Maurice Richard ici l'avance des des
solidaires et de 140 voix sur les kakis
c'était une circonscription libérale
mais marie-more petit la député sur
tente ne sait pas représente très bien
donc à suivre il y a des luttes et je
rappelle aux gens ce qui se posent la
question et la chef libérale on n'a pas
de résultats danser Henri Sainte-Anne
plus que dans Camille Laurent ici qui
est la circonscription de Paul
Saint-Pierre plein monde et Rosemont
Québec solidaire on le voit sur le Lille
a repris l'avance 342 voix d'avance pour
Vincent maréchal sur la coalition à
venir Québec avec 24 boîtes de scrutin
depuis très bien donc
luxe on verra comment ça va se terminer
mais Québec solidaire espérait
évidemment mieux oui mais il faut dire
que on a rien dans Mercier là qui est le
Plateau Mont-Royal on a rien dans dans
Verdun ou j'espère faire des gains mais
par contre la roue de Boissy je dois
dire que ça moi j'aurais parié sur
Audrey
Audrey gestionnaire pour parce que c'est
un parti c'est un quartier qui est pas
totalement urbain le c'est un quartier
qui
à cheval sur une partie d'urbanité puis
une partie de de quartier plutôt
banlieusard de Dan cycle du Nord à round
Boisy responsable que demander une
commission contre le racisme systémique
qui a été au premier plan pour la lutte
pour la laïcité mais
débattant contre la loi 21 donc
quelqu'un qui est très très marqué très
bien on a lutte contre le racisme ça va
être quelqu'un qui très vocal en chambre
si jamais il apparaît alors on verra si
ils atteindront le disque qu'ils avaient
Québec solidaire on parle de Mercier où
il y a pas encore de résultats Émilie et
Christian commentaire sur cette victoire
qui s'annonce quand même forte et
décisive de la carte Émilie
mais c'est sûr que c'est pas surprenant
ce qu'on voit en ce moment
la bataille ce soir c'était vraiment
pour essentiellement pour savoir de qui
va être composé le position et puis
comme on le disait un peu un peu juste
un peu plus tôt il y a beaucoup de comté
pivot à Montréal qui sont pas encore
déterminés la seule chose qu'on voit
vraiment pour l'instant qui est pas sur
une nouvelle information c'est la carte
c'est la carte de Laval où on voit que
la CAQ est en train vraiment de faire
des gains donc pour ne serait-ce que
pour les pertes à Laval qui sont pas
bien confirmés mais qui ont de l'air à
se confirmer ça semble être une très
mauvaise soirée pour le parti libérale à
ce niveau là et en fait plus de gens une
bonne soirée à part monsieur le Gaulle
disons-le franchement Christian les
conservateurs qui sont deuxième dans
plein de circonscription j'arrive pas à
percer il y a toujours une surprise de
ce soir de l'élection c'est une énorme
surprise puis elle vient pas du côté du
tout on l'attendait dans une démocratie
parlementaire de type Brit donc un parti
qui récolte 50% des voix c'est énorme
donc c'est une grosse légitimité pour le
gouvernement logo moi je l'attribue à
deux choses évidemment sa gestion de la
pandémie parce que c'était valeureux
même ceux des gens qui ont été critiques
mais un autre élément dont les
commentateurs par le passé je trouve les
supposés gaffes en matière d'immigration
c'est clair qu'il y en a eu deux le
constellation la violence puis le
dérapage de son ministre de
l'immigration mais pour le reste quand
tu le manifester son inquiétude pour
l'immigration je pense qu'ils s'adresse
au Québec profond c'est-à-dire c'est bon
commentateur il s'adressait au Québec
francophone profond et moi je vois un
lien avec le 50% actuellement pour le
reste le PQ sans me sauver
quelle que soit le nombre des députés ce
qui était énorme aussi on va voir
iridium c'est clair que s'il y a pas de
député c'est un gros problème puis le
perdant tout le monde le dit c'est
Québec solidaire parce que c'était
jusqu'à présent le parti nouveau le
parti des jeunes qui se posait en
opposition et c'est la confirmation que
les élections sont toujours en partie
faites de choses qui n'étaient pas
prévues moi le 50% de la CAQ je suis
renvoyé ça risque de bouger encore mais
vous avez raison de souligner que c'est
très élevé comme pourcentage très bien
mais les joueurs je vous je vous laisse
aller vous devez aller à à nos collègues
anglais on se retrouve à la première
résultats pour devenir anglaise les
voici dans saint Henri Sainte-Anne 20
voies de plus sur l'avocat Guillaume
clicher Rivard avocat spécialisé en
immigration qui
qui voulait espérer remporter Saint
Henri Sainte-Anne à avoir mais un bureau
on va se on va se garder d'allonger de
longues analyses là dessus
et on s'en va à nottaway voir des
résultats dans Gatineau Robert Bussière
qui tente de se faire élire et c'est
bien parti pour une deuxième fois donc
c'était une prise de la 4 la dernière
fois en Outaouais et ça semble se
confirmer dans Pontiac mais le sang
surprise
André Fortin ça s'est jamais été dans
une liste de circonscriptions en danger
monsieur Fortin qui qui va être élu dans
quelques minutes
si la tendance se maintient martine
Biron notre ancienne collègue est élu
dans chute de la chaudière donc Madame
Biron qui va faire son entrée à
l'Assemblée nationale
voilà elle avait fait le d'ailleurs elle
voulait annoncé Sébastien comme chef de
bureau ça a été un petit choc pour vous
l'aviez dit et depuis je l'appelle
madame Biron non non je blague je
l'appelle Martine quand même
félicitations d'avoir été élu juste
peut-être un petit mot sur l'outawa vous
en avez parlé le résultat qu'on attend
c'est celui de all mais malheureusement
pour l'instant on n'a pas de résultats
dans all une une série en tout cas en
théorie on verra ce que ça donne ce soir
la claque actuellement c'est pour vous
illustrer avec des chiffres très simples
cette montée gagne 12 % de pourcentage
les libéraux en perte 12 donc c'est
énorme c'est vraiment dans les
pourcentages c'est énorme et ça explique
pourquoi monsieur Legault même si sa
langue doit être mordurée passer la
campagne à ne pas parler en mal de
Justin Trudeau parce que les électeurs
qui l'avaient besoin d'aller chercher le
parti large le plus faible devant lui
c'est des électeurs j'avais voté Trudeau
il y a un an donc
il s'est vraiment retenu il y a eu
plusieurs
occasions au débat dans les points de
presse il y a un an il n'avait que de
parole sur Justin Trudeau et la menace à
la nation mais c'est une stratégie qui
certainement va payer ce soir en tout
cas c'est très payant pour l'instant
c'est très payant pour l'instant
évidemment qu'on va avoir des résultats
dans certaines circonscriptions qu'on
attend avec impatience vous voyez que
avec solidaire remonte on est rendu à 8
donc ça va être intéressant mais la
majorité de la coalition du Québec elle
est franche et les fortes des sondages
pour l'instant se sont pas trompés mais
il reste encore des batailles locales
intéressantes à suivre les sondages sont
un peu trompés
on verra effectivement plus 12 plus 12
pour la 4 - 12 pour les libéraux -5 pour
Québec solidaire moins 3 pour le Parti
québécois et plus neuf alors il y a tu
gagnes évidemment il partait à moins de
deux là dissolution
c'était à un point 5
réaction du maire de Québec avec une
pointe d'humeur Bruno marchand
voix d'amour sur Twitter j'ai entendu un
peu avant de féliciter le nouveau
Premier ministre François Hugo on ne
sait jamais sourire en coin ce sera un
plaisir de travailler à nouveau avec
vous pour notre capital national
félicitations à tous les élus et tous
les candidats pour cette élections il y
a un dossier litigieux qui s'en est
entre les deux là le troisième bien mais
c'était une référence évidemment à son
élection à lui à Monsieur marchand on va
ouvrir une petite parenthèse mesdames et
messieurs troisième mien ne vous
inquiétez pas on repart pas là-dessus
pendant toutes les missions mais le
maire de Québec nous a dit qu'on était à
Québec en émission spéciale
que il était incontournable dans la
prise de décision que si lui n'était pas
d'accord avec le projet qui va être
présenté ça se fera pas etes-vous
d'accord avec vous non c'est pas de la
façon de gouverner de la CAQ ils
prennent les décisions ils ont
bien changé je pense pas très peu
d'écart pour les élus municipaux je vais
vous dire que je le pense alors s'ils
veulent le troisième lien même si
Monsieur marchand n'est pas d'accord ils
le font très bien
on verra ce qui se passait de très loin
là mais c'est pas toujours évident
appel à la collaboration de Valérie
plante nous avons un félicitations à
François Legault et son équipe nous
avons hâte de poursuivre le travail pour
répondre aux priorité des Montréal et
montréalaises et des municipalités la
transition écologique l'habitation la
mobilité et la sécurité ce sont les
sujets qu'elle met au jeu
très bien alors madame plante qui elle
aussi à rencontrer tous les candidats
donc monsieur Legault et elle a beaucoup
de demandes Camille Lorin premier
résultat pour Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon Richard Campo qui est le
député sortant est en avance un seul
bureau sur 173 là vraiment les
tous les pékistes doivent avoir les yeux
rivés sur Camille Laurin pour la
prochaine heure parce que ça ça peut
faire mal si il arrivait deuxième il
n'arrivait pas à se faire élire monsieur
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon je rappelle
que pour l'instant en particulier
mais pour l'instant en particulier il y
a les yeux de la Madeleine en avance et
il y a Matane matapedia c'est tout après
Geneviève Guilbaud relu on va passer les
ministres du cabinet Legault réélu
Mathieu Lacombe en Outaouais réélu qui
était ministre de la Famille c'est des
larges majoritaires Rick Girard le
ministre des Finances réélu lui il a
presque reçu un avis qu'il allait rester
au finance mais pas aussi clair que dans
le cas de Monsieur Dubé François
bonardel ministre des Transports élus
et Rosemont ben le voilà Monsieur
Marissa qui a repris une nette avance
sur la candidate kakiste dans Rosemont
et Sébastien Desrosiers vous êtes donc
au rassemblement à Boucherville avec le
candidat du Parti québécois justement
dans Rosemont
exactement le comédien Pierre-Luc
Brillant bonsoir Monsieur brillant
bonsoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
résultats à ce moment-ci québécois est
en avance dans deux circonscriptions
est-ce que vous attendiez à être en
meilleure posture à ce moment-ci
les résultats sont très parcellents
encore il y a plusieurs circonscriptions
dont on se demande encore ce qui peut se
passer mais je pense que ce qui est le
plus intéressant ici c'est de regarder
le suffrage universel ou le Parti
québécois est nettement au dessus des
autres parties qui font pas qu'ils
seront qui formeront pas le gouvernement
je pense que c'est à ça qu'il faut
s'intéresser beaucoup puis ça nous en
dit long aussi sur notre mode de scrutin
en ce moment je pense que là il était
avec deux possibles
circonscriptions avec plus de de vote
que toutes les autres partis il y a une
question à se poser mais on se la posera
après l'élection et la question se
posera effectivement vous êtes bon en
retard sur le candidat solidaire dans
votre circonscription d'enreg
heureusement c'est votre première
campagne électorale qu'est-ce qui vous
fait croire que vous pouvez l'emporter
là où je québécois en 2018 n'a pas pu le
faire
en 2018 n'avait pas pu l'emporter dans
Rosemont qu'est-ce qui vous fait croire
que cette fois-ci vous êtes capable de
le faire oh ben c'est c'est du travail
le terrain en élection je vais avoir en
marchant sur le terrain avec tellement
de d'enthousiasme je pense que les les
gens qui sont qui sont pour la
souveraineté les pékistes sont très très
sont très présent en ce moment sur le
terrain puis ils veulent m'élite très
très fort je pense que c'est bon c'est
de bonne humeur pour le futur merci
beaucoup monsieur brillant merci
alors évidemment et vous allez entendre
mesdames et messieurs beaucoup pendant
qu'on voit que Manon m'a assez élu pour
un troisième mandat dans Sainte Marie
Saint-Jacques allons masser la cour
porte-parole de Québec solidaire ils
sont à 8 Québec solidaire je vous le
rappelle ils étaient à 10 avant et dans
Maurice Richard ils étaient en avant ils
traînent de l'arrière maintenant et si
la coalition Québec est à 92
circonscriptions en avance en ce moment
c'est notamment à cause de Maurice
Richard ou la CAQ est en avance par 197
voix mais aussi Enjou louis réel une
circonscription du Parti libéral où la
coalition Québec performe bien donc il y
a deux circonscriptions de plus où ils
sont en avance Camille Laurens vous me
permettez la carte est en avance par 134
voix monsieur Saint-Pierre pernandon le
chef du PQ et deuxième puis regardez ce
qui se passe à Laval il y avait cinq des
six circonscriptions qui étaient
libérales quand on regarde en 2018 5 des
6 c'était général aujourd'hui avec les
résultats qu'on a c'est quatre des six
qui sont
caquistes et dans sa la cinquième ici
Vimont c'est une avance de 150 voix sur
la candidate de la collection à Québec
donc pourquoi la carte est à 92
notamment Laval mais aussi à Montréal où
ils sont en avance dans deux
circonscriptions de plus que ce qu'ils
avaient en 2018
très bien on va voir la situation des
chefs bon évidemment monsieur Legault
était lu depuis longtemps Sainte Marie
et Sainte-Anne Dominique Anglade qui est
en avance pour l'instant dans coing
aussi ça devrait rapidement être une
formalité pour Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
Camille Laurin Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon qui traînent le moins là c'est
il traîne l'arrière donc il n'est pas
premier c'est pas 134 c'est contre lui
Eric duel même chose
Eric gène dans Chauveau avec l'écart qui
est là c'est inatteignable ou à peu près
mathématiquement on voit des images du
rassemblement de la collectionner Québec
Robert Bourassa en 89 avait eu 92 on est
on est dans on est dans ces eaux là au
Parti libéral on voit des images en
direct
à 19
c'est inatteignable
des images de Québec solidaires
avec l'annonce de la victoire de Manon
Macé Québec solidaire qui frôle le score
qu'ils avaient eu en termes de nombre de
sièges par rapport à la dernière fois
[Applaudissements]
elle a aussi des images en direct du la
permanence du rassemblement du Parti
québécois
et le Parti conservateur et vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure le candidat dans
Rosemont du Parti québécois parler de la
réforme du mode de scrutin attendez-vous
attendent entendre ça beaucoup ce soir
chez les parties d'opposition en disant
Parti conservateur à deux à 0 puis on
est à 12% du vol est-ce que ça allait
absolument nulle part
ça sert à rien de jouer dans ce film là
pendant une demi-heure ça arrivera pas
monsieur Legault il se livrait assez
député ah ouais on va faire une réforme
du mode de scrutin les amis il y en a 40
d'entre vous qui auront pas de siège
prochaine sélection c'est extraordinaire
comme proposition quand on veut gérer un
gros caucus et il a dit que la porte
était fermée
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur l'état de
l'opposition par contre tour de table la
partie
en termes de en terme de compter ça
reste à voir
les sondages à part le PQ en termes de
pourcentage de sondage c'est pas mal
dessus le reste c'est moins sûr c'est
pas l'effondrement que certains voyaient
pour le Parti libéral non ils ont une
grosse perte mais certains parlaient au
début de la campagne de 12-1314 pour les
libéraux dans le pire des scénarios
pendant que on voit que Gabriel ado
Dubois bien sûr et réélu dans coin
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour la carte
parce que on le disait au début la CAQ a
besoin d'avoir des personnes
ministrables à la Ville de Montréal elle
est ministrable et si elle devait être
élu elle a joué un rôle important pour
représenter la Ville de Montréal au
Conseil des ministres
on va aller on va aller voir alexandre
Duval qui est avec Carlos Letta ou qui
était du président de cette campagne qui
avait fait son meilleur culpa pour le
cadre financier on vous écoute Alexandre
écoutez alors Carlos qui est avec moi
monsieur l'état de voir que vous
conservez ben en fait que le parti
libérale conserve l'opposition
officielle mais tout de même s'apprête à
avoir moins de sièges que ce qu'il y
avait au moment de la dissolution
comment vous percevez ça pour nous
c'était important de de garder
l'opposition cruciale parce qu'avec ça
il y a toutes sortes de de de de budget
toutes sortes de temps de parole à
l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est
important de faire ça et plus que ça ça
nous donne aussi maintenant le temps 4
ans pour Dominique parce qu'il faut que
Dominique reste et elle va rester pour
Dominique puisse rebâtir et recentrer le
parti libérale pour qu'on soit prêt 2026
mais monsieur l'étape d'avoir quand même
moins de sièges ce soir que ce qui était
le cas à la dissolution est-ce que c'est
possible que quelque chose dans la
campagne de Madame Anglade qui n'a pas
fonctionné ah écoutez je vous dirai
d'entrée de jeu là on reconnaît
absolument Flac campagne en mal commencé
la première semaine les premiers dix
jours
n'était pas bon disons-le comme ça donc
par la suite après le premier débat je
pense que Dominique a été capable
toujours en gardant une grande rigueur
et très bien centré sur ces sur ces
lignes et tout ça elle a réussi à nous
ramener et à reprendre ce qu'on avait
perdu on avait beaucoup baissé en
première moitié de campagne pensez-vous
qu'elle ne manquait de temps je pense
que la manqué de ça je pense que ce
serait pris encore peut-être une semaine
et surtout et étant donné ce que ce que
la carte était en train de faire
monsieur le gars qui disait toutes
sortes de choses sous l'immigration
entre autres donc si on avait eu encore
une semaine ça aurait été mieux vous
avez dit Monsieur létal elle va rester
madame Anglade sauf qu'elle fera face
forcément un vote de confiance c'est
dans la constitution du Parti libéral
pensez-vous vraiment que les militants
vont la laisser continuer quatre ans
alors qu'on est dans un creux pour le
Parti libéral avec le résultat de ce
soir écoutez moi je vais démarrer très
actif au parti libérale je fais partie
de plusieurs commissions et je vais
rester très engagé et je vais faire tout
ce que je peux utiliser toute
l'influence que j'ai encore au parti
pour qu'il Dominique ganglade reste chef
de Paris c'est important on a besoin
qu'elle reste on a besoin qu'elle
refasse le parti Carlos merci beaucoup
alors Patrice vous l'entendez la
réaction de Dominique Anglade qui
viendra bien sûr plus tard quand elle
arrivera ici au Théâtre Corona dansé
Henri Sainte-Anne les militants étaient
pas trop surpris de la victoire rapide
de la CAQ ce soir reste très motivé
quand il y a des victoires libérales qui
sont annoncées mais bien entendu pour
dominer qu'englade ça reste un résultat
difficile
très bien merci merci beaucoup oui le
Parti libéral du Québec a fait lire 31
députés la dernière fois ils sont à 19
mais bon à 12 ce qui fait peut-être plus
mal encore c'est le pourcentage à 12% le
Parti québécois à 15 %, n'a que deux
députés en voie d'être élu enfin il est
il a été élu parce que Bérubé mais dans
oser de la Madeleine
ce n'est pas encore réglé regardez à Old
déjà ils avaient eu Gatineau lac Suzanne
Tremblay une boîte oui préliminaire
n'empêche elle est en avance sur la
députée sortante de Maryse Gaudreault
qui a beaucoup de racines à haul alors
on va on va voir on va suivre cette
course attentivement et
et pour expliquer la performance du
Parti québécois et dans la porte
pardonnez-moi Sébastien Isabelle le
poulet qui est en avance sur Mathieu
Gratton Nicole Ménard la libéral ne se
représentait pas ça
libéral depuis qu'on est jeune
Park c'est un château fort sur la
Rive-Sud normalement libérale qui
pourrait tomber ce soir laurier Dorion
sans surprise fanticella est en avance
sur dans market Enrique
bon lui ça va bien c'est réglé pour ce
soir au tout début il y a eu un peu
chaud mais il conserve assez facilement
il va conserver assez facilement sans
compter dans Prévost Sonia Bélanger ça
c'est le comté de Marguerite Blaye qui
ne se représentait pas d'un Laurentides
et il a kaki Sonia Bélanger qui a pris
le relais est en bonne voie d'être élu
ils Montigny dans René Lévesque ça c'est
une chasse le PQ
le chef Sébastien qui ne se représente
plus le matin Ouellet était un bon terme
c'est Sylvain royal avec le chiffre très
bien
parlons de l'Est du Québec si vous vous
demandez pourquoi le Parti québécois 15
% des votes en ce moment et seulement
deux circonscriptions il est en avance
c'est qu'il est deuxième dans 45
circonscriptions dans 45
circonscriptions au Québec actuellement
le Parti québécois et deuxième mais
c'est pas assez pour lui donner des
circonscriptions la coalition Québec à
90 passe la MAP dans l'Est du Québec
regardez ça ressemblait à quoi en 2018
ça ressemble à ça en 2018 ça ressemble à
quoi en 2022 ça semble à ça avec
seulement Matane mattédia qui tient le
coup pour le Parti québécois les Îles de
la Madeleine que vous n'apercevez pas
sur cette carte là les gens avec des
yeux de lynx ont vu le PQ1 PQ 1 ça doit
être dans l'appelerie mais c'est chaud
ça chauffe ça change d'un côté de
l'autre
monsieur Lachance conservateur est en
avance sur monsieur Ker dans les 7
circonscriptions de chaudière Appalache
le pcq est deuxième donc performant
compétitif dans la grande région de
Québec
intéressant parce que pour eux entre 0
et 1 c'est entre
c'est toute la différence du monde c'est
le débat c'est être dans la vie
politique on le vu avec la parlementaire
les points de prince à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une grande visibilité à
l'Assemblée nationale que d'avoir un
député il y a quelque chose de sain il y
a quelque chose qui est sain quand on
est 12% dans les sondages ont
normalement on devrait être représentés
à l'Assemblée nationale d'une manière ou
d'une autre
série c'est mieux de pas mettre l'argent
en banque
c'est peut-être la clientèle de base
monsieur kek se retourne un peu comme
lui contre lui parce que il dans les
dernières années c'était sa clientèle
une bonne partie est devenu clientèle
des conservateurs je pense que ça peut
du sens que jusqu'à maintenant chez ces
on verra des résultats lavals
Christopher ski qui réélu avec une forte
forte majorité deuxième mandat il est
l'adjoint parlementaire de sur le gros
Olivier vous êtes avec Michel Trottier
qui arrive deuxième libéral
pour exactement Patrice donc ici sur
l'île de Laval présentement il y a 4
candidats de la CAQ qui sont soit élus
soit en avance deux pour les libéraux et
en compagnie de Michel qui a été défait
par Christopher ski dans saints alors
Monsieur Trottier comment vous réagissez
donc à cette défaite ce soir ben écoutez
on a 4G de défaite encore actuellement
mais moi je tiens à dire qu'encore 30
000 vues votes à dépouiller tu fais que
je donne un optimiste de nature et donc
je vais attendre la fin de la soirée
pour ça par contre je tiens à dire que
pour les citoyens de Laval de
Sainte-Rose la démocratie a été gagnante
dans le débat d'idée qu'il y a eu dans
ce qui a été mis en place moi en tout
cas je trouve que le citoyen est gagnant
mais par contre je vais encore attendre
avant de concéder la défaite malgré
parce que quand même des historiques de
dehors quand vous conviendrez avec moi
qu'à Laval c'est tout un revirement de
situation la casque qui va détenir le
plus grand nombre de sièges mais
actuellement oui sont en avance à
certains compter mais par contre moi je
vais attendre pour voir parce que dans
les derniers il y a quand même eu des
remontées merci beaucoup alors voilà
Patrice chez les libéraux ce soir donc
on ne réalise pas l'ampleur de la
défense
qui va s'adresser à ces militants
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous savez que c'est comme ça
qu'on gagne
c'est vrai que soldat vous le savez que
moi c'est plus qu'un parti politique
c'est un mouvement c'est mon meuble
c'est mouvement là c'est vous qui leur a
dépassé
[Applaudissements]
Jacques qui nous écoute ici
qui remercie ces militants ils sont vous
avez vu que ça a bougé pour Québec
solidaire pourquoi ça a bougé je vous le
montre tout de suite dans Maurice
Richard à rudevoisier a repris en repris
l’avance c'est très très serré entre
Audrey Murray et Haroun Boisy alors
qu'est-ce qui est en avance on va suivre
ça ça risque André funticella qui est en
avance également sur le libéral dans
laurier de Riom il y a quand même une
bonne avance et on vient de le voir
Maurice Richard 55 voix
Verdun on a des premiers chiffres dans
qu'on voit Rosemont vincent Marissal qui
est maintenant une confortable avance on
a une
monsieur boulet on l'écoute
et dernier jour
absolument mais je suis vraiment fière
pour utiliser un terme que vous
connaissez je suis fier d'être un très
fluvien puis je suis vraiment heureux de
la réaction des personnes qui ont apposé
un X dans mon compte
du niveau de gravité qu'il porte la
controverse autour de vos proches moi je
veux pas faire d'analyse ce soir l'heure
est à la à la fête je veux encore une
fois féliciter tous mes collègues de la
mort ici du Centre du Québec et du
Québec qui est à substinction était
déclarée gagnant moi je veux ici pour
être avec les militants militantes et
c'est ce qui m'importe pour l'instant
il y a encore plein de dossiers de
préoccupation dans le comté dans la
région au Québec et je pense qu'on a une
équipe de personnes extrêmement
compétente pour continuer dans la même
monsieur boulet qui a dit on va
continuer est-ce que vous craignez à lui
a demandé est-ce que vous avez crainte
c'est un impact alors en gardant les
chiffres il dit il y a pas eu un grand
impact en tout cas
dans ma région et un peu partout au
Québec on a des chiffres pour Verdun oui
la circonscription chouchou de Luc
Fernandez ce soir donc Verdun les
premiers chiffres on voit que Québec
Solidaire est en avance 19 boîtes de
scrutin dépouillés avance de 207 voies
pour Madame zagamendes sur la députés
sortante Isabelle mélanson ça va être
intéressant ah oui j'ai oublié de
regarder où était les coalitions Québec
mais ils sont ils sont ils sont quand
même un peu loin pour peut-être espérer
avoir cette circonscription puis dans
Saint-Lary Sainte-Anne la
circonscription de Madame
Anglade et des temps en avance dans ce
circonscription monsieur
saint-pierre-lamandon est en déficit
dans la sienne et dans Maurice Richard
donc on l'a vu juste avant Québec
solidaire qui est en qui est en avance
également donc pour l'instant ils
auraient un gain en fait ces deux gains
là mais ils ont des pertes ailleurs ce
qui feraient un gain un gain absolu dans
Rouin je vais vous demander après
d'aller dans Rouen Sébastien dans
tâchereau réélu Étienne Grandmont élu
élu pardon dans Tachereau il remplace
Catherine Dorian Roy alors les voici les
résultats bon avance bon avance pour
Daniel Bernard de la CAQ qui était
député libérale qui a été conseillé
municipal jusqu'à tout dernierment et
qui est candidat de la CAQ ça il y en a
certaines qui vont faire plus plaisir à
monsieur Legault que d'autres celle-là
va certainement faire plaisir à monsieur
Legault madame sir tout à fait puis on
verra peut-être un peu plus tard pour
l'analyse j'aimerais aussi qu'on
souligne un gamin il y a quand même
42 bureaux de scrutin qui est 71 223
voies d'avance aussi pour Monsieur
Lamotte nous on peut parler d'une
certaine tendance mais je me garde un
petit jungle parce que c'est encore tôt
par rapport au nombre de bois c'est très
bien dans Marwa risky réélu dans Saint
Laurent ça faisait pas de doute on lui
souhaite d'ailleurs
la meilleure des chances elle est on
nous disait
en train de donner naissance à un enfant
alors c'est merveilleux félicitations
vincent Marissal relu d'un Rosemont pour
Québec solidaire c'est réglé c'est
bouclés dans le cas de QS à Rosemont et
rouba Gazal également dans Mercier
l'ancienne circonscription d'Amir cadire
dans Mercier donc Sherbrooke qu'est-ce
que se passe pendant Alexandre Leduc
réélu dans Hochelaga Maisonneuve
deuxième mandat pour Monsieur Leduc dans
Sherbrooke dans Sherbrooke ça tient au
Québec solidaire au moment où on se
parle dans un océan de bleu poudre avec
534 bois d'avance pour Christine Labrit
sur Caroline St-Hilaire vraiment une
bataille à finir entre les deux mais
pour l'instant Québec solidaire semble
avoir le dessus dans cette bataille pour
Sherbrooke saint François oui
Saint-François c'est une circonscription
qu'on regardait pas de pas de débat ici
dans Saint-François
2100 presque 2200 voix d'avance pour la
député sortante contre une candidate
quand même de qualité Mélissa généreux
la directrice de la santé publique
parlons-en c'est ça qui c'est ça qui
fait mal à Québec solidaire on voulait
sortir de l'île si on avait une bonne
soirée on pouvait être encore plus
compétitif dans Saint-François on a une
soirée ordinaire au Québec solidaire
reste beaucoup de vote à Montréal
pourcentage va bouger mais nombre de
sièges on pensait être capable d'aller
chercher deux trois quatre sièges de
plus que les disques qu'on avait à la
dissolution fallait aller chercher
Saint-François ce sera pas le cas avec
une avance comme celle-là donc
certainement une petite déception parce